We snuck up on you dirty bitches.
It's only 1215 here on the east coast or the west coast.
If we're in the east coast,
this would be like the normal starting time.
This is like the east coast version of the fucking podcast.
People say,
Hey Joe Rogan.
Um,
how the fuck do you guys,
uh,
do,
do you make any money off of this podcast?
How's that work?
I'll tell you one way or orange benches.
It's a little thing called desk squad.
Dot.
TV.
Check that shit out.
You don't a to shot.
You can go by that.
You could buy that high quality Brian Red Band designed work of art and you
could have it and you can walk around it every show.
We go to Matt Desk Squad fans in the audience.
This is where the shirts come from.
Go to death squad.
Dot TV.
There's two versions of them.
Uh,
this is the newest version and with the sexiest cap in my opinion,
I like this cat better.
This is the dopest cat and a,
there will be more.
And there's tee shirts and there's bumper stickers.
And what does the new website I shop?
Squad dot.
TV shop squad.
Dot.
TV But desk.
Why that TV will take you there.
So if you can't remember that,
cause I can remember that.
He's already told me twice.
Go to desk squad desk squad.
Dot TV.
You got it.
All right.
You fucking freaks on it.
Dot Com is our other sponsor.
That's Oh and periodically.
Ladies and gentlemen,
let me just say one thing.
We've had a few other sponsors and corporate sponsors.
People like audible.com people like ting.com.
Alienware the reason why,
uh,
we,
if we're in business with any company,
it's because they got something good for you.
You will never,
we,
we have turned down stuff that's like high profile sponsors that I don't agree
with.
I don't like what they're selling.
I don't want to do,
I don't want to say what they want me to say.
I'm not interested in that.
What I'm interested in,
I think there's plenty of people out there like Ting,
the mobile company that has tanks.
No.
Um,
no cell phone contracts and a,
an excellent phones.
I really love the Samsung Galaxy s three it's fucking gorgeous.
I,
I'm,
I'm really gonna have a hard time going back to the iPhone.
It's such a little puny screen.
I think I'm going the other way.
Since apple scrutiny with my preorder,
I thought I'm just going to go,
not get this new iPhone is just go galaxy s three should,
we're going to hook,
we're going to hook it up with Ting Ting.
You know,
they didn't even,
they weren't even supposed to be sponsored on this podcast today,
but we're bringing them up just because that's our,
our,
our entire approach to,
uh,
to advertising on this podcast.
We are,
anything that we're involved with is something that we believe is a great
product.
With Alienware though,
the thing that I really love about Alienware is how much love they give to up
and coming MMA fighters.
I everywhere I look on Strikeforce,
on Bella tour on UFC,
there's constantly dude's without Alienware logo.
That means to me that a company is putting their money behind a sport and a,
when a company is like alien ware that's owned by Dell,
this huge computer company mean that to me is a bold,
it's a bold chance buy them.
And I think a bold moves like that should be supported.
And that's why we use a computers on it.
Dot Com is another sponsor.
It's the only one that I have a,
a financial investment in.
And again,
the only reason why I would do that is because I wholeheartedly believe,
uh,
in the way the company operates and in what they're selling.
Um,
the big one,
the big a product that,
that I'm always pushing his alpha brain and you don't need Alpha brain.
I've said this a million times before,
but I always have to say in case this is the first time someone has ever tuned
into this podcast,
uh,
if you eat healthy and your,
you know,
in fit,
you probably don't need it.
It's not a necessary part of your life.
But they are nutrients that have been shown to enhance your brain's ability to
produce neurotransmitters,
to,
to fire thoughts off.
And,
uh,
from a person that knows the difference between the way I feel when I'm eating
healthy.
You know what I'm eating nutritious food.
And when I'm supplementing my diet and when I'm not doing that,
there's a difference.
I feel it.
I feel a tangible difference.
I feel a difference in my performances the way I'm a big,
I'm able to form sentences the way I can come up with ideas quicker.
I mean I I really believe in that Shit's all fired together in there,
so it makes sense.
That makes sense.
Absolutely.
Listen,
ladies,
gentlemen,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I might have smoked a little pot before this.
She has to do a wee bit and I might be a little long winded.
What I'm saying is on dot coms caught some cool shit that I support 100%.
The first order of 30 pills.
There's a 100% money back guarantee.
Um,
you all right buddy?
I think you're not supposed to start it.
No,
he did.
Cause to cause weight too vague.
It could be real how long?
Longest to,
but if he did do it,
I don't think you should snort it.
I don't think it's supposed to go through your digestive tract.
It's food.
Um,
we also have kettle bells and battle ropes.
We're starting to sell fitness equipment now and again,
it's all stuff that I use.
Stuff that I think is,
uh,
some of the best strength and fitness can be conditioning equipment that you can
get this kettle bells.
So it's fucking fantastic workout.
Use a code name Brogan and you will save yourself 10% off all supplements.
And again,
with the supplements,
you have a 30 pill.
The first 30 pills,
they 100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
Just say it sucks.
No one's trying to rip you off.
Everyone's trying to sell you the best shit possible and stuff that I would use.
All right,
that's it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Oh and,
and it,
and Brian,
anything more to say?
Oh yeah.
Desk Watch show tonight.
We're uh,
at the ice house tonight.
It is a Oh Thompson jurors out are you should fears and that's how we roll.
We got a ours.
You fear.
We got Joey Diaz,
we've got dom motherfucking IRA IRA.
We got Greg Fitzsimmons in the house pitches and Doug Benson and Brian Redman.
Did I say,
you know you're in there to bitch.
Um,
and me.
Yeah,
I'll be there too.
It's going to be awesome.
House comedy.com.
Yeah,
we,
we do these a on a regular basis here and there's another one here.
I'm in Toronto on Friday night at Massey Hall that she had sold out Sun.
But if you want tickets to a comedy show in your La,
you can come to the
ice house show here.
A squat show Friday.
All right,
bitches.
Mack Danzig's here.
We're going to get it done properly.
We forgot to do the Panto.
We start ranting trying my day.
Joe Rogan podcast.
This is way better.
Mack Danzig is,
uh,
I think you might be podcasts haunted my friend.
No,
no,
no.
We're going to fix it this time.
Yeah,
we're going to fix it.
We were going to get this done.
See you demand a proper setup.
That's what it is.
The fucking set up at my house is ridiculous little God damn stupid web cams.
That's why I have a studio that's a,
in the process being put together,
that Shit's going gonna take months.
Yo.
Somebody said I should make a little video of where,
you know,
show look what it looks like in the beginning.
I might do that.
Time lapse.
It just set one in the corner and yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That'd be cool.
Yeah.
Now I've never done anything like this before,
so it's kind of exciting to build something up.
But Mac,
Dan's like my humblest apologies.
I'm money retardation and my tech,
his mine and ours,
she fears are,
he did a podcast with him.
We had,
we had a good conversation.
We were,
you know,
it wasn't an video or whatever.
He does his quad guest audio.
But yeah,
we,
we had a really good conversation and it was afterwards I was like,
oh man.
He was,
I think he was more disappointed about it.
Even then.
I was,
I mean he,
he felt pretty bad about it and it's just,
there's nothing you can do.
And I was like,
you really,
you emptied the trash to,
you didn't just delete it but you emptied it.
And he's like,
yeah,
well I was making,
I had to make more room and
Oh,
just think God get a new laptop.
Bitch.
He,
we had a great,
we had a great conversation.
Yeah.
Well we,
there's 40 minutes that we may or may not put back on,
but what happened with us was the second file was corrupt.
Um,
it wasn't worded over.
No,
it wasn't working on Ustream.
And um,
the,
the thing,
the MP three recorder went off and then I had to turn them back on again.
Remember Brian and I take the battery off and the file afterwards was corrupt.
Wacky ass.
And you share it worked.
It was that,
that's crazy that he both haunted is fuck yeah,
that was a big goddamn disaster.
But we're going to correct that.
You're going to add the 40 minutes to this one when you put it on.
Take you to do that.
We can make this the the full well,
I just hope we don't get redundant.
The problem was,
and you have a conversation like the,
you know,
like would I,
there's a lot of shit that we set that I want to make sure we cover it.
So fuck that out of the pocket.
Okay,
cool.
Go step.
Pitch.
All right.
Unless we're going to send someone back into the archives to edit it.
I Dunno man.
A lot.
A lot of internet drama,
man.
If you've been paying attention to this,
uh,
this crazy video that all these Muslims are responding to all over the world,
this ridiculous.
You told me about it last,
last week.
Yeah.
The,
the Christian fundamentalists.
Yeah.
Have you been watching all the reaction to it?
I haven't.
No.
Well,
France,
in their infinite wisdom,
someone has decided today to,
uh,
publish a cartoon with Mohammed in it.
They're just pushing it like there's gay.
Yeah.
We get to the place it,
how do they smoke?
Is it like this we're going to,
because Mohammed make a fart noise with his face.
Yeah.
There's something about the way they hold cigarettes that was really annoying.
Right?
How's it like this?
Is it this?
They call the fats out.
That might be something to it was it?
This is it.
This is something,
there's something wrong.
It's like,
hey,
fuck face this.
You know,
this is the way to do it.
This is the right way to do what you have.
Full use of your hands.
What's all this crazy shit?
It's like the tea,
the tea thing.
Yeah.
We did that.
Smoking it like this.
Oh,
I just got another text from dice clay.
Tell me how awesome is special came out.
He's so fucking psyched.
Dice Clay said he did a special and he said it was like the old day said Dude's
were standing up and screaming.
He said there was a mad desk squad fans in the crowd too that he,
he had a a bunch of guys coming up to him that said they heard them from the
podcast.
Yeah,
he's,
he said it was like one of his best specials ever,
so that's the only time you're allowed to host cigarette like this.
That just
minds me of the people that they got the tea or the coffee or whatever.
It actually reminds me of one of my favorite scenes,
Mulholland drive.
When you do you,
are you familiar with the Merrill Lynch fan?
Right,
usually linchpin.
Yeah.
And He's,
he's holding the coffees like Napkin need the requests a napkin first he sips
it,
sends it down,
then spits it out into the Napkin.
Oh my God.
This is the finest expression when the world like
it was the,
the,
that's what's up man.
That's,
that's funny stuff.
And David Lynch's like
so weird isn't it?
Yeah,
because movies are still like,
sometimes you leave and you go,
what did you just do to me?
You fuck.
I know I trusted you.
It's like the ability to express emotions,
you know,
through film.
The,
the ability to,
to make the,
the viewer you to evoke emotion and the viewer is strange emotions that are very
peculiar.
Like nothing that really,
you can,
you can put your finger on.
At least I can't,
as far as articulating it like with,
with language,
it's just one of those things you got to watch.
You feel creepy,
you feel a little bit,
you know,
like it's a little bit,
hello.
We're involved in it too.
Like at the,
like,
it's sort of a dark humor.
It's,
it's,
it's really cool.
He's able to play with ideas and notions and just,
you know,
pervade them with film.
That's pretty,
I've really enjoyed some of his stuff,
but I've,
I've walked out of a few of his things going,
what the fuck?
What
did you walk out of?
Inland Empire?
No,
that was a,
was that wasn't that bad?
I liked that one.
Yeah.
Who is this?
Who is the stars of inland empire?
Um,
that's going to be the Lord there and yeah.
And um,
uh,
man,
what's his name?
That the same guy that,
that uh,
that played in Mulholland drive,
Mulholland drive.
I thought the end of it was just too fucked up.
I was just like,
wait a minute.
Why this is it?
It's just,
it just ends right here.
But that's the tough is,
is I don't,
the way I look at it,
his films,
I don't think that they're always necessarily,
uh,
a plot or a story to figure out is this just an experience?
Yeah.
And experience and,
and you can take it for what it's worth.
And there's all sorts of theories as to,
you know,
what was really happening in the story and everything.
And then there's one major one that everyone adheres to is,
as far as Mulholland drive goes,
but I think it's like,
man,
it's just the experience.
I don't even try to figure it out.
It's like a psychedelic experience.
It's like you,
you can't force yourself back into the here and now,
like,
like regular reality and try to,
you know,
figure everything out while it's happening.
It's just,
you just have to
just gotta go with it.
Yeah.
Submit yourself to it given to the experience.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but,
uh,
I remember blue velvet,
that was it.
Dennis Hopper.
We had the,
the,
the mascot and he was the greatest show intent.
And I remember he could pull it up.
God,
it was so intense.
It was so like,
oh my God.
Like that Guy Dennis Hopper for sure has seen some real life insanity.
There's no way he could be that intense about some shit unless he,
I know he seen something man.
Yeah.
Pulling that out of your ass.
That shit was too real.
That blue velvet huffing character.
Yeah.
And that's,
that was,
that was one of the greatest scenes ever been.
Lynch had just done such,
such bizarre stuff.
But that's how it makes you feel like almost creepy.
Yeah.
If you watch them,
I have a DVD that has some of it's called,
I think it's called the lost films of David Lynch and it has some of the things
that he was doing,
uh,
when he was in college and when he was at coming up like his first like some
animation stuff and,
and some of it's pretty disturbing.
And then some of it is like,
wow,
like this is,
you know,
like borderline genius stuff.
At least,
you know,
from me
creative standpoint,
it's pretty cool.
Oliver Stone's lost his fucking mind.
Yeah.
This movie tried to put out with these two dudes live and with this one chick
and they're both banging her and there's no problems.
Oliver,
fuck you.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Silly.
That movie's more ridiculous in the Avengers.
No,
I'm cool with Oliver Stone.
I don't have,
I don't think he sucks or anything.
Like,
I don't know.
I platoon,
yeah,
Wall Street.
Oliver Stone's is brilliant.
I just,
I'm not going to see your drug war movie about the noble drug dealers who are
bolt in love with the girl.
Fuck you.
There's just so written with cliches.
It's like how much coke were you on when you came up with that idea?
I,
I often
think back and almost wish that that Tarantino would have followed through with
his script and the natural born killers himself.
Cause that really would have loved to see what his take on it.
I loved Oliver Stone's take off.
I would,
I would too.
Yeah.
But yeah,
there's been two movies like that were tenanting I said that he didn't really
enjoy the,
the finished product.
It wasn't really like what that was that and um,
Christian Slater movie.
Sure.
Romance.
True Romance.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Just fucking brilliant movie.
How you can complain about anything about true romance.
Damn.
That was a good movie when you have a baby,
you know what I mean?
Like if you were,
if you were to write a standup
routine and then have somebody else doing it,
even if they hit it out of the park,
it'd be like,
well that's not the way I would
do.
You know,
it'd be the worst writer.
Terrible.
But yeah.
Um,
but true romance,
the movie,
the finished product was a fucking work of art.
That's one of the all time best like troubled romance and you know,
fight for each other to the death.
Absolutely.
That's a,
that's a lot of positivity in that movie,
man.
This beat perfection and the imperfections of life.
That's a bad ass fucking moving at your show.
Cat.
Christian Slater was a bad mother fucker in that movie.
What happened to that dude?
How does that happen where a dude does like a true romance and you would figure
it,
he'd been movies constantly if he can do that.
What he did in that moving w did he do cuffs before?
After that?
Cops?
Yeah,
I remember that with a k it was just like,
well one of his like his dog movie.
Was it a dog?
No,
no,
no.
Like a silly comedy where he was like a cop or so like an undercover cop or
something like that.
It was just one of those things that like actors,
they got to work and everything and understand that.
And so it was just one of the things where it's like,
wow,
like you're kind of starting to take a path on,
uh,
you know,
Kinda corny direction.
You know what I mean?
Like I watch guys do that all the time who are great actors and they were able
to repair it by picking and choosing the projects that they want to work on.
And then they redeem themselves every time.
But he is kind of,
uh,
I think that was when I was starting to kind of look at him.
Funny,
you know?
Well,
I looked at the whole world funny once ice cube started John Family comedies and
I was like,
what the fuck has gone,
have you ever seen that picture online that they,
it's the first picture.
It's one of those,
the Internet pictures where they took a photograph of him,
I think he has an AK 47.
He's sitting there with be real from Cypress Hill and lucky band.
Fuck yeah.
And it says at first I was all like,
I've got that.
And then at the bottom it chosen with like,
uh,
like fishing pole,
like on a vest,
like Rolex.
Yeah,
he's got like a,
like he's like out on a boat
or something.
He's got a life vest on like a big life vest all the way up to his neck.
And he's like smiling,
all goofy.
And it was like,
but then I was all like,
it's weird seeing him in those beer commercials,
you know,
look,
I can't talk shit about people selling out.
I did fear factor,
you know,
and I did it twice.
I took some time off and went back and did it again.
So I can't talk shit about if you got to make your money,
you gotta make your money.
But for us it's very odd to see.
I mean I'm not criticizing it.
Oh my God.
That's so
I love these fucking things.
Internet memes,
man.
Make me laugh so hard.
I spent like four hours
the other weekend on um,
know your meme.com you ever seen that website?
I think that's what it's called.
It know your meme.com and it's like this site that,
that documents pretty,
pretty thoroughly all of these different Internet means Techno Viking to that
Jesse slaughter girl.
You were,
do you remember her?
It's sad in a way.
It's,
it's fucked up.
I mean the,
she's like some 11 or 13 year old girl who got like all into gossip in some
little scene or subculture of music and everything.
And you know how Friday,
no,
no.
This is some girl were like,
what happened was she became so popular in this little subculture and everybody
just jumped on her and was like ridiculing her and all this stuff gets,
she was going around saying that she was sleeping with all these dumb emo
artists and everything in some rock band and you know,
she's like a little kid and she was doing all these webcam things.
You know how it's popular now with youtube where everybody just sits in front of
their computer with like,
they're,
they're like clothes hang from the door knob in the background.
They're like,
you know,
like talking about whatever,
giving a review on a movie or talking about whatever.
And she was doing all that stuff and getting really,
like scandalous with it.
And so people just were just tearing her apart and her dad got on like a live
webcam broadcast.
It was like the one Brian Brian did a,
uh,
like a parody of that.
Yeah.
A lot of people did.
And he's a,
yeah,
he's like,
he's totally talking out of his ass.
He's like,
he's like,
I'm talking to the cyber police and I've backed,
traced all of the emails and if you,
if you ever come near my daughter talk about her,
he wants is his big quote quote.
He goes,
consequences will never be the same again.
There.
There's something like that.
It was just,
it was,
it was sad.
I mean,
people screw up their lives on the Internet.
Oh yeah.
Here's a,
here's a parody of it and that's Brian,
that was Brian.
Brian,
we got to see the real one first.
You're going to see the real one first.
So you know,
still yours.
It's the,
um,
it's sad.
Well,
you know what you're also seeing in that video,
you're seeing a guy who was not aware of the playing field.
Yeah,
no,
totally.
That's why it's so interesting.
It's fascinating because that's,
there's a guy who doesn't understand that you're in your,
do you just put something out there in the Internet virally?
Like you don't really know what that is.
Do you like Jack?
And that's going to hit millions of people.
Like the idea never crossed his mind that he would be able to yell something
into a video camera and then it would become like a meme and people would do
parodies of it.
He thought he was
talking to a select group of people who are like tormenting his kid or whatever.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
That's still you.
You fuck yeah.
Try and trick me.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
it's,
it's weird to see like viral videos,
you know,
like everybody knows about the goat,
see guy,
you know the guy who pulled this asshole apart.
And it's particularly disturbing because in the photo he's wearing a wedding
ring.
He's like tugging his ass hope and
the original guy.
Can you imagine if it's just somebody that we know and he's like very ashamed of
that photo and he's just like a normal guy.
He's like,
look,
I was just really drunk.
Yeah,
you could be.
But the thing is,
the ways plan at it,
it's like this guy's done that before.
I mean he's,
he's just clawing open his asshole the way he's doing it just doesn't seem,
you know what,
for a second there,
when you read,
I said clogging opened his ass hole and you'll reach for the board.
I was like,
Oh,
I swore,
you know why I had to do radio this morning?
Close my eyes.
If you put that shit.
No,
you can't put that up.
You can't see that the people at home,
they don't deserve goatee.
No ma'am.
But I had to do regular radio today.
Sucks.
It doesn't suck.
I mean,
they were real nice,
but I forgot like how rarely I do that now.
So when I do it,
I always have to go.
Don't swear,
don't swear.
Like I'm not a professional anymore.
Like any,
at any second,
something come out of my mouth
special.
You just not censoring yourself with these ridiculous censorship ideas that
it's,
yeah,
it's just,
to me it was,
it was,
it was strange.
Uh,
being aware of it and thinking about it just for a second.
The thing,
and this is like the reality of most people's lives that are on radio.
Everybody's under the gun.
You gotta be real careful what the fuck you say?
Yeah.
I haven't done radio in a while.
When I had like my little 15 minutes of fame right after the ultimate fighter
show,
I was doing a whole lot of radio shows.
And
for those of you don't know,
Mac Danzig won the ultimate fighter season.
What seems like six loose about five years ago.
Um,
it,
it completed in,
what was that,
2008 I think,
or two.
Two days ago?
Yeah.
2007 yeah.
I think it was 2000 2008 yeah,
it was.
It was like right when it completed.
2007 2008.
You're an alumni that's a very prestigious group of humans as you have won the
ultimate fighter.
Well,
yeah,
I guess so.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it was definitely an experience.
It's a huge accomplishment.
It's not just like winning a fight.
They're just getting through the experience.
I mean,
I've,
you know,
I watched the tapes,
I've seen it.
I've talked to dudes about what it's like the chore for sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I knew what I was
into when I did it.
So my whole idea heading into that show was just to win.
Like I,
you know,
there's this guy,
I don't know if you know who he has a,
he doesn't really do Jujitsu anymore,
but he was one of the guys that I first started training with it in Los Angeles
when I first moved out here named Fernando Vasconcellos.
Probably he won the worlds in Jujitsu as a black belt when he was 16.
He's one of the,
like the,
like in the gym,
one of the best prodigies in the world.
Like,
I mean,
I,
I've never rolled with anybody anywhere near as good as him.
Like,
yeah,
like,
I mean,
maybe like,
like Robert Drysdale is like,
you know,
has that same type of ability,
but Robert's also way bigger than me.
But,
uh,
Fernando was just amazing.
And I remember one of the things,
you know,
he had already kind of given up on,
on fighting and everything.
And he told me before I left,
he's like,
just remember,
just do this to when you're there to when you're not there to goof off and,
and like,
you know,
you can do whatever you want but,
but the goal is to win the show so that you can have a career and you know,
better yourself and keep moving forward.
And I was on there as soon as I got in,
there was all these guys,
half of them were like deer caught in the headlights.
They were just like,
Oh man,
like I'm actually on the show and what's going to happen and are they going to
surprise us or you know,
what's going to go on?
And then the other half of the guys who were just there to,
to,
to be goofballs,
hoping that they get enough exposure to,
you know,
put some pictures up on their myspace page or get laid or whatever they wanted
to do.
And,
and I was,
that's why everybody's like,
Oh,
you're so grumpy and you're so angry and everything.
It's like,
well dude,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to win this.
This is what I'm doing.
Like I'm very serious about this.
Do you find that that's a weird position where a lot of fighters find themselves
where they have to also try to be a showman?
They have to like you,
you see the encouragement that uh,
people get from trash talking because it sells paper views.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
my whole thing is the whole reason why I'm doing this and maybe I didn't know it
when I first got into it,
but now after looking back of years of a career,
like over 10 years I've been doing this and reflecting,
it's like I picked this because one,
it's artistic too.
It's fighting and I love,
I just like the fight and,
and three,
it's,
it's honesty.
It's about being authentic.
And that's from the beginning to the end for me.
So like,
you know,
like the marketing of the fight,
the preparation of the fight and the actual act,
the art of,
of,
of doing it live in a spontaneous way.
And I,
I do it because it's about being honest with yourself.
There's an,
once you get in there,
there's no script,
there's no faking it.
That's what's going to happen.
And I love,
I love that.
I love putting myself out there and like,
you know,
it's a,
the ultimate sacrifices,
ultimate commitment.
And so,
um,
when you start to like fake beefs with other fighters and you start to like,
you know,
play up all this stuff,
in my opinion,
you're playing a game with your authenticity,
you know what I mean?
And,
and that's a heavy load to bear.
Like,
take someone like Chael Sonnen who buy for like,
I,
I like chill a lot.
I like,
I like his shtick.
I like him as a person and I like him as a fighter,
but that's a heavy load to bear to say all this stuff.
And he's great at it.
I mean,
he's a great talker.
He,
he's got amazing,
all,
you know,
all sorts of funny things.
I mean,
I laughed my ass off,
listen to him,
and he's really good at it.
He's the best at it.
It's amazing.
But it's,
you know,
do you really want to do that when you have to step in there and be 100% real
and the in that moment and you have to like back up all this stuff that you
said.
I mean like if he can come to terms with it,
then he can,
and that's,
and that's up to him.
But my whole thing was I want to,
to be the person that I am inside and outside of the ring.
And I,
and like when I was on the show,
I was,
I was mad.
I was angry that,
that there was all these guys who weren't serious.
They were screwing around.
They were drinking every night.
And then there were some guys that were serious,
but they were too scared from the whole situation.
Just scared them,
you know?
And they,
they were just shutting down.
And I watched like,
especially guys on my team,
like I watched their morale breakdown,
especially with the way Matt Hughes was training these guys.
And,
and they just,
you know,
they just broke.
And I was like,
man,
like,
what's with these guys being nice to my face and then being all silly behind my
back.
It's like I would never choose to live with you ever in any other circumstance.
And now I not only do I have no contact to or from the outside world,
but I'm,
I'm stuck in a situation where I can't even take a walk in the neighborhood to
get away from you guys.
So if I saw somebody and I in,
they're talking all kinds of shit on me and they don't like me and they're
drawing little cartoons of me and this like juvenile way.
I'm trying to like win this thing.
I see them and I'm like,
dude,
don't talk to me like I'm your friend.
Like,
like fuck you.
You know what I mean?
And like,
people are like,
oh man,
well he's,
he's just,
he's so grumpy and he's mad.
Well,
it's like you would be to,
I mean like,
this is what I do for a living.
This is how I'm going to,
well,
you had already had a lot of experience for you,
the show you'd already fought soccer.
I can and I mean,
you were pretty well known as far as like guys getting on the show about as well
known,
uh,
you know,
and fighter outside of the UFC get.
And so,
yeah,
what ended up happening was when I got on there,
I took the confidence that I had from all that experience and I just turned it
into like,
like I'm,
I've always been very respectful,
but when there are people who disrespect the sport and,
and disrespect this,
you know,
I mean,
I understand it's a show and they pick goofballs like Richie hightower and stuff
like that.
But when you take a bunch of guys who are disrespecting this thing that I've
dedicated my life to,
um,
I'm like,
fuck you guys.
Like I'm winning this thing.
And,
and I took my experience and I turned that into like,
um,
Alpha male type of,
you know,
attitude.
I was like,
fuck this,
like who's going to beat me?
Like I'm,
I'm taking out all you guys and that's the way I operated and that's what won
the show for me.
You know,
how much older are you than the average guy on the show?
I think,
uh,
about four years older and that isn't it?
That's what that is.
That is pretty big.
Yeah.
It was like 27,
I think when I was on the show.
And um,
most of the guys were in their early twenties.
Such a big difference to me at 21
and me at 27.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
I was harder to 21.
Yeah,
it's hard not to be,
you know how,
how long ago was that?
Was that before,
like you started breaking it into acting and everything?
Yeah,
I was 21 in 1988.
Okay.
88.
That's when I first started doing comedy.
Right,
right,
right.
So that was what,
like a big transitionary period for me.
Uh,
no more competition than going into comedy,
but I just remember being so stupid,
like,
yeah,
like in the ways of the world.
So it was just,
I wasn't fucking dummy.
And I think today when I talked to 21 year olds,
I'm so impressed with the,
like how much information kids have today and just how the world really works.
It's a,
it's so different than when I was 21 when I was 21.
If you would come up to me and asked me a political question,
I would have been dumbfounded.
Sure.
I would not have had any answer.
I wouldn't,
I don't know how the process works.
I would have no business voting
but,
but you know,
of course I could.
And uh,
and did I think I,
uh,
I voted for somebody who lost,
I don't even remember who the fuck it was.
Dukakis.
It probably was.
It probably was what way back then?
Yeah,
I was probably,
I had a very strong democratic girlfriend at the time,
so I'm sure she probably talked me into vote.
Phony Democratic Babbat maybe.
Yeah,
no,
I don't remember what it was,
but I just remember being so dumb.
21 but 21 year old kids today,
they're,
they have way more information in their head.
Yeah,
they do.
But I,
I still think there's,
I don't train process.
You just have to go through.
Yeah.
I mean I think the information is,
is there,
but I feel like,
um,
I don't know.
I,
I personally look at,
look at some of the young people that are like in their early twenties and I see
a lot of the same like passive aggressive ways of handling,
handling social situations that you would,
that were sort of the norm with kids when I was 16 or 17 I don't know.
I mean,
I guess the,
I guess it goes both ways,
but there's,
there's definitely a huge access,
a much bigger access to information now,
especially because of the Internet and everything.
And I think there's more open minded people and,
and I hope,
I hope that's the way that we're going.
Yeah.
The idea that kids are more street smart or more worldly in the days gone past.
The,
the reason why that makes sense to me is that you don't just let your kids
wander on the street anymore.
Right.
Like people used to just open the door when they were young,
you know,
when they had 10 year olds and the 10 year old to just go out in the street.
Nobody fucking does that today.
Everybody keeps an eye on their kids because you know,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
You can't do that anymore.
So guys have a younger generation.
Just to,
a little while ago,
I mean even when I was a kid that wasn't like a really highly discussed topic of
child molesting cause it wasn't like you went out of the industry,
you thought there was child molesters.
Everyone know,
even brought it up.
Nobody even fucking warned me about my mom did put the fear in me.
She was kind of like,
uh,
like on the cutting edge of,
of all of that.
She really,
I mean,
you know,
she,
looking back at it,
like when I was a teenager,
I was kind of,
I kind of started harboring resentments cause I was like,
man,
like when I was five and six and seven years old,
I'd have these nightmares about like getting kidnapped and stuff.
But man,
like all that,
like because of just the,
like she wouldn't go into detail,
but she'd be like,
Hey,
look,
you know,
if somebody approaches you,
you know what I mean?
You don't know them and you,
Like you gotta be careful.
And she,
she educated me on all that actually saved me one time.
There was the man,
it was,
it was the craziest experience because when I was,
um,
I think I was 10 and uh,
I lived in this sort of old fashioned suburban neighborhood,
which is very near all this stuff that was once rural farmland and had now
become industrial parks.
And I would cut through these industrial parks to get to my,
my one friend's house.
And I went over to his house to try to find him and he wasn't there and I had a
scooter or something like that.
I was like trying to go back and I had to cut through these woods to get to this
holiday inn parking lot and then cut through the parking lot to get back over to
my neighborhood in this,
these woods were really,
there was the really small stretch of woods,
like very small,
just a little wooded areas,
probably like maybe a hundred yards or something and no one's ever there,
you know,
it's the little path in between the parking lot in this call to sac.
And I get up there and I start walking my scooter cause I'm on a dirt path and
all of a sudden there's this guy standing there and he's like,
he's,
I remember him,
he had like a,
like a button up tee shirt but no tie.
And he had like,
uh,
like,
like reddish hair,
like a red little light bread beer.
And he was like,
he's like,
hey,
how you doing?
And I stopped dead in my tracks and I was just like,
oh shit.
I was like,
this is what,
this is what she was talking about.
He's,
and I was like,
Eh.
I was like,
hey.
And I went to like go pass him.
He's like,
hey,
come on up.
There's a lot of other kids playing up here.
He'd go,
go ahead up.
And I was like,
Oh wow,
like you're like,
and I hurried up and I was just like,
ah.
I didn't even say anything.
I was like,
I was just frozen and I turned around and I,
I took off and then it was,
it was so,
it was so crazy.
It was like there was,
there was kids that had,
that had been abducted that,
that this,
this guy was kidnapping kids and I don't even know what he,
what he was doing or whatever.
But he was there at that Holiday Inn and they were,
they were following him throughout western Pennsylvania and I think they
actually found it,
but that was the guy.
And I was like,
whoa.
I was like,
wow,
like what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
Like,
like an eye if it wasn't for my,
so it was like all those nightmares and it was probably worth it because,
uh,
you know,
she sometimes fear is,
is an important thing to have.
Just instinctively,
you know,
like somebody can let you know that,
hey,
it's probably not going to happen,
but you got to know the difference.
You know,
you can't be naive
though.
The moment you realize that you're on your own out there making decisions and
that you can get roped into something like that.
Yeah.
Here's not a factor for me,
Joe.
This is not at all.
I was like six or seven,
I think,
I think was seven.
And uh,
I was at the library and some guy came over and show me these,
uh,
I was looking at these monster books,
like I was into like Frankenstein the wolf man,
and he got,
the guy goes,
I have a lot of monster books in my car.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
Oh you do?
And he goes,
yeah,
do you want to come see you?
And I go,
okay.
So I would just,
I was really young and I just laughed with them and I'm walking out the door
with them and the librarian,
uh,
sees him and she yells,
she knew my name.
She goes,
Joseph,
you get away from that man.
You get away from that man,
you know.
And I started running and the guy started running.
Oh.
And then I realized,
Oh shit.
So I started crying.
I was crying like crazy.
And then,
um,
she,
uh,
the library and said that he'd just got out of jail.
That's a serious close and Keller,
while if that librarian didn't see what was going on,
but isn't that a horrifying job for the librarian to,
I mean,
she did it and I'm in,
thanks her.
I might be dead.
It might not have ever survived.
I don't know what he did.
He went to jail for,
I don't know what he's willing to do to not go to jail again.
You know,
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
But the,
um,
the librarian has to think that like,
while all these kids are walking around her library reading books,
just to think that someone can come in and snatch him and fuck him.
He could have had a big cock there.
Joe.
Ryan,
you need to shut the fuck up man.
You just Kinda know when did not say,
when did it stop trying to be silly all the time.
Oh Man.
The um,
well the podcast is working,
so yeah,
this one,
this one's a lot.
This um,
yeah,
I received,
this is what I tried to avoid it,
um,
the,
uh,
the kids or get like,
if you let your kid out today,
like that's like a recipe for disaster.
Like nobody wants to just let their kids roam the streets today.
I know that's a shame
because it's like we need and in touch with the earth,
we need to be in touch with,
with,
you know,
like just experiencing society and experiencing other people and,
and man,
it's like we've got a shelter.
Our kids to a certain extent.
You know,
I,
my,
my daughter's only,
she's going to be four,
but it's like,
like she's the most important thing in the world to me.
And it's like,
I,
I don't want,
what was,
it was Mckenna that said,
this is like,
like he was saying that,
that he struggles with this as a parrot and he's like,
what will it be like a cynical intellect who's like sheltered or slack jar jod
um,
consumer halfwit of the Horse Shit handed on from Donald I or you know,
like in our case of what we're talking about now,
it's like Eve eve even worse.
Possibly,
you know,
like something bad happening because you're,
your kid gets in a situation that they shouldn't be in.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the big worry.
I think that's what we're so aware of today that we weren't aware of was fun,
but it is a legit concern and be able to say,
oh,
we have to live without fear.
Yeah.
Maybe.
SORTA,
but look,
there's some horrible shit that's happening out there for real.
You can't just deny that.
So to,
to roll the dice with your babies.
It's not,
it's not so easy to do when you're aware,
when you're aware of what the fuck is going on in the world.
We've got to figure out how to stop all that and make something,
an environment where you can let your kids go again.
But that's,
that's changed radically just in the last like 30 40 years.
You know,
the way people raise their kids.
I mean,
I,
I want to homeschool my kid.
I just don't have the resources to do it.
And,
and a lot of people when they hear that,
you know,
they're,
they're stuck in the same modality in the same way of thinking.
It's like as everyone else.
And they're like,
well,
what do you mean you're going to homeschool?
And the how is she going to be adjusted socially?
It's like,
well adjusted,
adjusted to what,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like,
I mean,
there's plenty of other experiences that you can have socially with people and
get to know yourself and get to know how to interact with people without going
to the institution of public schooling.
I mean public school like pretty much,
I mean ruined me and like,
and when I try to tell people about that,
they're like,
wow,
I would say ruined me.
But like,
it's,
it definitely sent me off onto a,
as spiraling into a different path and it helped me become the person that I am
and everything,
my rebellion against that.
But it's like,
like,
uh,
I didn't have to,
you know,
I don't want to put my kid through that,
and I don't think it was an isolated incident either with,
with the public schools that I had.
What was wrong with your,
your experience?
Well,
I,
I went,
I immediately,
you know,
I was already in public school from like first to fourth grade and it was like
this,
um,
strange school where,
uh,
you know,
you had half of the kids are more than half were like these rich,
Yuppie kids and the parent,
the,
uh,
the teachers really like favored them.
So like,
I guess it was kind of like a social experiment in a way.
Like the teachers were very favorable to these kids.
And then there was all the kids from where I was from,
which was like kind of like the poor area and a lot of them were like
misbehaving white trash type of kids.
But they were,
you know,
they were um,
they were just kids and I was sort of stuck in the,
in the middle I was from like the poor area and we just got treated like crap.
We got treated like second class citizens.
It was almost like being a minority in this,
in this situation.
I would thought that it was really weird and almost all the teachers there were
just hand out worksheets,
stay in your desk,
that whole thing.
You know,
I came from Montessori and kindergarten,
which is a completely different structure of learning and we,
we understood mathematical stuff like,
like multiplication just through physical work.
Like they have these beads that you count on almost like an abacus instead of
writing things down and doing like the worksheet type of work.
And so I understood all of that.
Like,
even going into first grade,
I just wasn't able to articulate it in the same way,
like this memorization way where it's like two plus twos for,
you know what I mean?
That,
that type of stuff.
It was,
it was all just,
you know,
like hands on.
And so I was just like,
what is with you could choose what you want to do in Montessori,
uh,
in public schools it was just like,
you know,
they try to keep everybody in line and control and understand why they have to
do that.
But the classrooms were big,
there was no individualized attention.
And then when I was from fifth grade to eighth grade,
we had moved to Virginia and then all of a sudden I became the minority,
which is,
which is fine,
but,
but it was,
it was very interesting neighborhood.
Yeah.
We moved through and like an all black neighborhood.
And um,
the,
the school,
especially the school,
like the neighborhood I lived in was like 50,
50,
but like,
the school that we went to was like,
I think it was like 88% black or something like that.
And the,
I just watched like,
I mean nobody cared about the students.
There were fights pretty much every day.
It was kind of reminded me of like the footage that I see of prisons,
the way fights would just break out and all of a sudden it was just this crazy
thing and I was always this like small little kid,
you know what I mean?
And I was just like,
you know,
I was like interested in these fights and everything and I thought they were
pretty cool but at the same time it was like I couldn't get involved with that.
I mean I was like four foot something,
you know what I mean?
I was like a little kid in lot of these guys had already gotten,
they're man size by the time they were in seventh or eighth grade and I was just
like shit.
And I was just watching it happen.
So I would resort to,
you know,
like my way of getting along in that situation was resorting to like class clown
ism or whatever because I couldn't like beat anybody up at that age and you know
what I mean?
Or like stand my ground that way,
but I would,
I,
I could at least win their favor by,
you know,
telling the teachers to fuck off or whatever,
and they,
and they thought that that was really funny and I was screwing myself up the
whole time.
And then it was like,
okay,
well these people,
like the kids that really didn't like me,
you know,
they didn't like the most of the black kids didn't like the white kids.
It was just the way it was.
And so at the,
the very best case scenario,
you'd be in a situation where you were ignored and the worst case scenario you'd
be fucked with all the time and picked on.
So,
um,
the best thing to hope for is being ignored.
It's like,
well,
where do you look for your role models at in that situation?
Not.
And as a kid,
people would always tell me and be like,
well,
you need role models and male role models.
And I was just like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
I don't need that stuff.
And looking back on it now,
it's like they were right.
You know,
you do look for role models and you look for people to set an example of,
of what to do to become a man or to,
you know,
to just move forward and grow up and become a chore.
And so I started looking at the,
I was like,
well what about these guys?
And there was these always a little group of heavy metal guys and Metallica
shirts and long hair and everything and they were just smoking cigarettes all
day long,
skipping school.
And then I felt,
I just was like,
okay.
And I started falling into that and then it was just like a downward spiral from
there.
And then,
and then once I moved back up to Pennsylvania and there was all these rich white
kids who thought they were gangsters,
I was like,
wow,
you guys are really faking.
They hated me because I was skateboarding and stuff.
And so I was like,
you know what?
I was like,
I'm done with this.
Like I don't want to be forced into this situation.
Like I want to hang out with the people that I understand.
And I,
and I hung out with older kids all the time.
We were already out of high school and,
um,
I just,
I was done with it and,
and,
um,
I abandoned,
I was pretty bright,
you know,
I band and like the possibilities of,
of moving forward with academics and,
and I've struggled with that for years and years and thought to myself,
well,
you know,
what if I,
I was regretful.
I was like,
what if I,
you know,
would have kept going to school and I could have gotten a degree in science that
I want it to or maybe become a,
a biologist or like,
you know,
done something in,
in one of these fields that I'm really interested in.
But looking that as I've gotten older,
that regret has started to fade because I'm like,
you know what?
Like,
I think I did pretty damn good for myself.
You know,
I think I did one of the things that,
that really spoke to me,
you know,
which is fine,
you can't have regret for taking a pursuit and enjoying the path.
There is no rigor.
There's,
there's,
there's a choice.
And,
you know,
and then there's life and there's the idea that it would have been better if you
went one way or another way.
Yeah,
it's hypothetical.
The beautiful thing about education is you have access to information that no
man before you had ever had in any university or your computer.
Yep.
Uh,
your,
uh,
your iPad or your kindle,
you can just fucking read book after book after book after book.
And if you know,
you've really pay attention to what you're reading,
you can get a fucking fantastic education without actually having to go
somewhere and have somebody riding on it.
Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
It's just like,
like one,
uh,
I and I agree with that completely.
I was just,
um,
uh,
for a while,
somewhat regretful because of the hypothetical idea of,
well,
if I did that,
that could have been even better.
You know,
it might have been really enjoying my life because I,
I would like to be,
I would like to travel and,
and,
and be one of those people who just lives in the rainforest for weeks on end,
get stung up by mosquitoes and just,
you know,
documents insects and knows every single tree frog and finds new species.
That is really interesting to me.
That's like,
could have been you in another light.
Sure,
sure.
And,
and so,
you know,
like,
and I would win when things are bad,
that's when you always start to,
to look in to your regrets.
And I had many bad times throughout my entire career and,
and you know,
there was times that I was like,
man,
like I shouldn't have taken this path.
You know,
it's just,
it's part of life,
you know,
you question,
uh,
what you're doing at four and everything.
And the,
those were the times when I,
when I look back and wish that I would've done those things.
But yeah,
now,
like as I'm getting older,
I really,
and,
and I hate,
I hate to like put it like a,
like a negative spin on it,
but like I'm seeing how much of a sham the,
the,
um,
the academic institutions are in colleges are,
you know,
one of my best friends has a,
has a master's degree at Ucla and he's going to get his phd.
And it's just,
I mean,
he's not doing it.
He's doing because he can't do anything else.
He can't get a phd programs paying him,
but he can't get a,
um,
a job doing anything else.
And he just was watching people just get,
get fed basically lies even even an what's supposedly a prestigious institution
like the University of California in Los Angeles.
And it's like,
man,
I would rather,
I'd rather sort through the information and find it on my own,
just like you said,
rather than,
you know,
get some kind of a degree and,
really have nothing to show for it.
I'm not putting down people who get degrees or anything like that,
you know what I mean?
I say,
I think it's,
yeah.
Yeah.
But,
but uh,
the,
like you said,
the information is out there and,
and um,
if you really just want the knowledge just to have it,
it's there for the taking if you got the time to do it.
Yeah.
It's a matter of just immersing yourself in a topic.
The information is just readily available.
I think living in regret is a very dangerous thing.
Absolutely.
Put yourself in a mindset.
It's a very dangerous thing.
I think.
You know,
you've got to just appreciate the now well,
I always tell people it's,
it sounds completely silly,
but it's a great way to think about your life to live your life as if you were
the hero in your own story and the movie starts today.
How do you go forth?
What do you do,
do,
do with the hero would do,
do with the person that you would most admire would do and everyone can do that.
We can all be in a movie where the hero wakes up and realizes he's been a
fucking dip shit half of his life.
It's time to pull it together for sure.
For sure.
You can do it.
Anybody can do that.
I think.
Yeah.
I think for me it was,
it was being regretful or feeling regretful was a coping mechanism of,
of just being down and having depression.
And it's like,
well,
you either,
you either get through that,
are you,
you don't,
this is the,
uh,
the Vegas Times as we talked about this on the podcast for B one that will be
whispered throughout the ages.
Last one,
the last podcast.
It's a conspiracy of the chair.
Yeah.
You moved out to Vegas to try to,
you know,
to further your MMA career.
But,
uh,
like a lot of people,
you found Vegas to be a very scary hollow freakish fucking town of depression.
Yeah.
It is.
I mean,
not all of it.
Well,
happy out there like pendula that's happy out there.
I don't know.
I would imagine it really is being horrible,
horrible.
Listen,
there's,
there's some guys,
they're like,
especially guys that I trained with that still live out there and they seem
content and happy.
And I don't mean to put these people down.
I mean,
these people,
I respect them.
And I like them.
They're my friends.
But in a,
in a certain level,
they're simple.
And I don't mean simple like retarded.
I'm talking like they,
their landscaping.
Yeah.
Well,
but yeah,
maybe even not so quick.
That's almost like simplicity,
like manifesting,
like being knowable.
But,
but I,
I feel,
no,
I feel like these guys that are able to,
I almost envied them at the time.
They were able to honestly live their life.
It made me,
they're suppressing their,
their hate for their life,
but I,
it feels like they're content with their life.
They come home every evening and they play Xbox or playstation and then they go,
when they train,
they train their ass off and then they play Xbox or playstation.
And on the weekends they either go play paintball or they go to a strip club and
they live their life that way.
And it's like,
you know what man?
Like,
like that's cool.
You're if you're in.
But like,
I don't know.
I mean,
yeah.
So I mean I had just won the show.
I was presented with this contract knowing like how fickle the this the sport is
and how easily you can get forgotten and,
and like how easy it is to get dropped from your contract.
I was like,
well listen,
I've got a,
there's nothing in La,
there's no great MMA teams in La.
There's nothing,
no one here to train with.
I've got to take this for all it's worth.
I had already been going to Vegas for a while,
you know,
every before every fight I would always go out and stay with gray.
I'd been doing that since the design stays before co,
even before coture over opened up a gym.
And so I knew all those guys,
forest and pile and Jay Heran and Martin Kampmann and gray.
And so I was like,
I'm going to move out there with them and I'm going to train it.
Couture's and Tyson Griffin's there now and like,
you know,
it's a really good situation.
We're just,
I'm going to have the best training partners and I'm going to work my ass off
every day and I'm going to give this the best shot that I,
uh,
that I have.
And what happened was I went out there and I realize that like it was just so
competitive.
There was no,
um,
there was no nurturing the athlete.
There was nobody saying,
Hey,
if you pay me,
you know,
percentage of your purse,
I will be there for you every day.
I will monitor your training,
I will help you out.
We will study your opponent and we'll disk.
It was none of that.
It was like you go in,
you spar,
you are in a war every day,
whether it's a grappling day or the standup day,
it's,
it's a physical war and these guys are very competitive.
They've all got the Alpha male type of personality and,
and all the fun got taken out of it.
I mean,
I would go there and those guys would go there too.
Everyone hated it.
I don't care what those guys say.
They're my,
they're my friends.
Everyone hated it.
Gray was one of the top dogs in the room.
Nobody could touch him.
Like you know,
once he got to a certain level for a while he was just a wrestler and you can
catch him and submissions cause he didn't know any better than a standup,
wasn't that great.
And then he turned the corner real quick and Greg got really good real fast.
It was a ride around the time that he beat Frankie Edgar the first time they
fought and a right around that time he had gotten really good.
No one could touch him and it seemed like he was just on top of the world and he
was hating it the whole time too.
And he was just putting up with it and all of these other guys I know they feel
the same way and we'd beat the crap out of each other.
We'd have so much pressure on us.
Everyone has a ton of pressure for every fight.
That's the way the sport is.
You go and fight,
win or lose,
it's time to come back.
Do you want to come back to the gym and see the inside of that place again?
I know I didn't I,
and then I would just immerse myself in,
in going to remote places and doing photography and like really experiencing
nature,
which is what I loved and it spoke to my soul.
And so I really liked doing that.
And when I would do that instead of like I was saying before in the podcast
saying that that got lost instead of feeling refreshed like,
oh I was,
I spent a week and a half,
you know,
in the desert and I experienced this timeless beauty and all this stuff I was,
I was like,
man,
I want to just go back out there again and I don't want to go back to the gym
and I don't want to stay in the,
it became a job and no,
no longer became the creative,
fun thing that I love doing.
It became an absolute 100% job where I was like,
okay,
time to go to.
So was it the overly competitive nature?
Was it the lack of structure?
Was it the fact that the Wa it wasn't being done correctly then everybody was
just trying to cayo each other all the time.
It
was,
it was all three of those things and um,
uh,
115 degree weather,
that was another thing.
And then just a man,
it was,
I don't know,
there was,
there was no unity.
There was no feeling like it was like we were all friends and we were all cool
with each other,
some more than others.
But there was always this underlying thing of,
especially if you're in the same way class,
well my,
I might have to fight you one day,
so fuck you.
You know what I mean?
Even though we were colon,
we're cordial with each other and all that.
I watch,
I watch other fighters come to the gym.
Like good fighters would come to that gym all the time because it was a hub.
You know,
you're in Vegas,
maybe cornering another fighter and so you're going to hop into extreme couture
because that's where everybody goes and that's where all the good guys are.
And you're going to train or like guys would come out for a couple of weeks and
like Jay Horan and Mike Pyle would just run the fucking clinic on those guys and
be mean about it.
You know what I mean?
They weren't like that,
you know,
like really like,
it wasn't like they were angry,
but man,
like they would put it on these guys and it was this real like Alpha male
competitive thing.
And this is competition and,
and that's one way to look at it.
You know,
a lot of people might think like,
well that's how you have to be.
You have to be like that.
But I don't think so.
Um,
if you look at the way that,
that both gray and I are training now and I respect the hell out of gray because
he's been training at a high level since he was 12 with wrestling,
you know,
and um,
even before that,
he's always been wrestling since he was five or something,
but he's been training at a high level,
like hard,
high,
high level workouts.
And he knows the difference.
Now he's training smart and that's what I'm doing now.
Um,
I mean,
I still spar and stuff,
but I'm not in there getting hit,
getting the shit beat out of me being the shit out of other people.
Just to try to put myself through a fire to simulate the idea of what a tough
fight might be.
I've been in plenty of tough fights.
I know how to get through them and know how to deal with my mind.
I don't need to prove to anybody that I'm tough.
I don't need to prove to myself that I'm tough by getting the crap kicked out of
me every day.
What I need to do is love the sport again,
love the technique,
love the art and,
and uh,
man,
just,
just go out there and,
and,
uh,
you know,
learn again,
learn,
learn the techniques again and then apply them.
Apply the techniques that work.
That's what I was my trainer.
Now Chip Reli,
he's,
he,
the guy's like a genius man.
And I do not use that word.
You know what I mean?
With,
with,
with anybody,
you know,
like he's,
the guy's a genius in that respect and he's giving me,
he's like teaching me a whole new language as far as body mechanics and
wrestling and grappling and just the fight game in general.
He understands it on a whole different level and he's giving me this whole new
language to work with and I can,
there are some words that I'm going to use and put into my vocabulary and some
that I'm not.
But that's when your personality comes out.
I think we were talking about that before.
That's why it's so interesting to watch the art of mixed martial arts because
you watch people's personalities manifest in the way they fight.
Yeah.
Which brings up what you talked about earlier with jail.
How difficult it is to put on a persona then go into the octagon and compete and
have it be real.
Yeah.
Cause you see the stark difference with him.
You see his bravado and that and that.
The,
the,
the shtick that he taps into and he's amazing at it.
But,
but will you see the contrast in between that and him when he walks into the
ring?
He is not like looking at the crowd and like,
like you know,
doing his,
his little stick anymore.
He is just a man focusing,
he has to like focus even more because he's so used to being in that persona,
you know what I mean?
He has to and you see such a difference.
I mean,
look at him after the innocence Silva fight.
The way he was saying,
it's like a,
he was like broken for a moment.
You know what I mean?
He's a tough guy.
He's amazing competitor.
He'll,
he'll get
well right away.
He tried to fight Jon Jones right after that.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Yeah,
a bad motherfucker.
He is.
He's one of the baddest,
yeah.
The uh,
the shit talking is unparalleled.
Mohammed Ali would have fucking hated it if he had a about rigged with Chael
Sonnen.
I mean,
look,
if it was a boxing match,
you with a Bach jail sentence,
ears off.
But if it was a shit talking match,
I say that I would take Chael Sonnen over Muhammad in a fucking heartbeat.
You know,
why?
Cause chill would sit in front of his computer like a fucking maniac for 10
hours coming up with the right shit to say.
Whereas Muhammad Ali would try to act on the fly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
no,
you're right.
You're right.
And I,
and I agree with you,
however,
all the,
his,
his art of trash talking was not,
uh,
none of it was,
he didn't have the supply of,
of information that the Internet had it for us.
So it might have been much more poetic with his trash talk shore and original no
chill,
chill is great with it.
And he's very much so like a,
uh,
like a Joe Frazier type.
If you,
if you could like take it,
take a boxer and say like,
what type of,
what type of a fighter would Chael Sonnen it'd be if he was a boxer back in the
day,
it would be a Joe Frazier for sure.
Tinder.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Get inside,
get inside,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's interesting when people,
I mean that to me is one of the best examples of the,
the fact that we're moving forward as a society,
as chaotic and crazy as it might be.
It's a,
it's everything of today is better than what it was,
you know,
in the 1950s.
I mean like anyone,
everybody talks.
Massiano was the best retired,
undefeated Massiano what I've done,
this mosque,
Yana what a broken Ali Tyson would have ran through Marsianno like fire through
bushes or our box Dorian's not the worst.
I mean I love racing,
I love,
Love,
love bug.
I love the history of it now,
but in sugar ray,
I'm going to use this example.
Sugar Ray Robinson was amazing and he was,
he was ferocious rate.
But to say that that he could have hung in there with like,
like Roy Jones is prime like,
like boxing people all over the place that are listening to this are saying
blasphemy now.
All Roy Jones is the,
it's like they love to discount the new guys.
These guys were,
are amazing in comparison to like just what they're physically capable of.
Then then,
then the old the then,
okay.
Roy Jones is way too big.
That's a weird,
okay.
Okay,
well keep it.
No,
you're right.
He,
you sugar rate did go up to fight light heavyweight.
Yeah.
Collapsed.
But okay,
so,
so let's,
he was,
if you want a tricky one,
man,
I don't know about that
direct example.
How about Roberto Duran?
I think Roberta,
the red would have,
would have run through most of most of the,
the old guys in his weight class.
You know what I mean?
He was a real one 30 Fiverr.
Yeah.
You know Roberto Duran,
even when he fought at one 47 he's just going up there to fight sugar ray
Leonard and stayed up there.
And then when as high as 60 and 68 he fought Iran Barkley.
Woo.
That was beautiful.
What?
He knocked down Barkly I was like,
Holy Shit.
Here's a guy
who's got like a serious research reached disadvantage and he's playing the
outside slip on the outside game with a guy who's,
who's got to reach
guy who destroyed Tommy Hearns dangerous striker.
Yup.
That's when I ran Barkley was a fucking beast.
Who is a strong punch or Matt took a lot out of Berkeley,
who the fuck hey and Davey Moore boxed up Davey Moore and you're like,
God,
Tim.
No one thought.
Everybody thought Roberto Duran was done.
The birder Duran ahead.
The loss to sugar ray Leonard in this humbling no mas fight and he won in the
first fight.
And then the rematch,
he quit and he liked the,
there's all sorts of speculation as to why he did it.
The reins from him being paid to take a dive to him being sick in the ring.
Fuck knows what it was,
but something,
something.
Some of them at that moment something broke and he,
uh,
he was humiliated for years.
It took a long time for him to come back to the,
the public's acceptance.
Yeah,
man.
I admire those people that have come back.
Look at,
look at foreman after he lost all the,
he took that hard man.
He took that hard,
but he came back.
Yeah,
you got it.
You got to give him credit.
I mean,
regardless of how silly the whole,
you know,
name and all your kids,
George and being like a crazy religious person and having a foreman grill,
all that stuff,
he's,
he's still,
he's done some amazing things that,
that are truly admirable.
And it's like people that can come back from that.
That's,
you know,
the,
those are,
those people are my inspiration,
you know?
Yeah.
George Foreman didn't box from the time he was,
I think he was in his twenties till he was in his thirties.
And he was like completely fat and out of shape.
And I remember he had a comeback fight and they put it on like the,
uh,
like it was like Trivia.
Like it was like what former heavyweight champion and on,
you see him in his comeback fight and you'll,
you'll look at me like,
oh my God,
this looks so silly.
Like,
look it,
I'm like,
what port George Foreman and the next thing.
And now he's on HBO knocking out Michael Moore to be the oldest heavyweight
champion ever.
Michael Maura was my favorite heavyweight at the time.
And I remember just being like I was,
I was so distraught when I saw that I was like,
this has got to be fixed.
Like I was,
I was a little kid at the time that I was like,
ah,
I can't believe that just happened.
You know,
cause I was,
I was hoping that more was going to end up eventually fight and Lennox Lewis,
like they were both really,
they were undefeated and ranked really highly and you know,
Holyfield and Bo were still very major players in the heavyweight gave at the
time.
And uh,
I was,
I was hoping to see that match up in that just squashed everything.
Maura was never quite the same.
Michael Moore was a tweener and really he was like one of the greatest,
yeah,
one of the greatest light heavyweight champions ever.
Michael Moore was a destroyer at light heavyweight.
But then he goes up to heavyweight and there those dudes are big man.
Those dudes are really big.
Those Klitschko fellows.
Like what the fuck is that?
That guy was on the plane with us.
We,
I forgot where we're going.
I think,
think it was Montreal.
And he was,
uh,
he was on the planet.
The guy stood up,
he's a giant,
he's this giant,
Eh,
just super athlete dues are bad asses and they're very good.
And it's j I know it's a shame
to cause people have a,
they,
they bring like boxing historians and people that fancy themselves as boxing
experts that like know about the old times.
They have some sort of nostalgia or some personal like nostalgic connection to,
to these old fighters.
And that's great.
And these old fighters were great and they did,
he like acts of human endurance over time,
span of 20,
30 years sometimes that are amazing and had so many fights and beat the shit out
of themselves just for the,
you know,
to,
to continue on in their career and,
and to,
to make the public happy.
And they,
they really destroyed themselves watching what happened to all these guys like
Joe Lewis and Lamada Inn and you know,
like Archie Moore and,
and all these great people.
But the actual skill,
I mean,
we're at a higher level right now and I hate it when people don't want to accept
that.
And they don't want to talk about that.
They're,
they're just like,
oh no.
Like,
you know,
you've,
you've got to give credit where credit's due,
but,
but you can't,
you can't compare the best old fighters to the best fighters nowadays.
You know,
even with the heavyweight,
I mean,
I hate heavyweight boxing.
No,
I don't really watch it.
But even with the heavyweight division being as dismal as it isn't,
shouldn't take away from how excellent these Klitschko guys are.
Yeah,
they are excellent.
But then I'll be tuning into like,
you know,
whenever this play and then whether it's showtime or who have this.
And I'm like,
who the fuck is this guy finding nobody to fight?
Yeah.
The boxing heavyweight boxing is just not in a good place.
Right.
I mean,
unless there's like a fight at the press conference,
like a David Hay and that other dude,
what the fuck's that guy's name?
The guy that,
uh,
I forget his name,
they had some crazy brawl at a,
at a press conference at all that's manufactured,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't think this one was David Haye punched him in the face with a bottle in
his face and his hand.
Really?
Yeah,
it wasn't manufactured.
Do you remember when,
when Riddick Bowe knocked out
Donald or knocked and knocked him down on stage that if,
if you ever Google that Riddick Bowe Larry Donald,
Larry thought this was it luncheon that he,
he hit him with the two punch combination
that was like,
it was brilliant.
Larry Donald had no idea that he was going to do it to him.
He,
they,
Larry Donald Still Dobby sucker punched him.
I mean,
well,
I mean
I'm not giving him credit like as if
that was awesome that you did that,
but the combination was,
it was brilliant.
He was,
they were standing there face to face and Riddick Bowe just dipped down I think
through like a left hook and just cracked him right on the chin.
And there's like,
if you watch it in slow motion,
there's a second where Larry Donald's Chin just snaps and he's still like
standing there like dumbfounded.
And then Bo comes down and like dips and hits him with an overhand right.
What was the arguing about?
It was just the same tired boxing thing where two guys up so we can see it.
Yeah.
Go Larry Diary drs conference.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Did they fight after that?
Yeah,
that,
well that was the press conference for the actual fight.
You know how many days away from the fight was that man?
Yeah,
yeah.
He cracked him.
I mean he got fined and like all this stuff happened,
like,
like they keep the commission came down on him and everything.
But I feel like these guys are always,
you know,
every single fight that we have though.
Like I love boxing,
but boxing is desperately trying to promote itself and that's why you see like,
like all these little scuffles and all this stuff going on,
you know?
Yeah.
I think,
I think it was,
yeah.
This is it.
Yeah.
So I'm getting excited about the upcoming Riddick Bowe Larry Donald heavyweight
fight.
This could change your mind.
Oh my God.
Look how he dips into it.
Solely fucked up.
But it's wrong.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not condoning it,
but he swimming Riddick boats today.
Oh Man.
It's terrifying.
Yeah.
That's
find anything Riddick Bowe today.
Brian,
he's a,
you listened to him talk and it's like,
oh shit.
Yeah.
And he's only like 40 something.
You know,
his,
uh,
his transformation hasn't even been gone.
Yeah,
I know.
And we were talking about that before last week about how it's just,
it's scary because the,
there's,
there's no science.
It can really tell you what's going on with your brain.
I had so much on my mind not to make excuses,
but that's just the way it was.
Was it the death of your,
so that's back then.
That's back to the muscle is fine.
Yeah.
This is when he was,
okay.
Yeah,
he was a,
this was when he was the champ.
So if you can find something of him now that I look at a Riddick Bowe if you
just Google or a youtube Riddick Bowe today talking the second one down.
Looks like him today when I'm sure it's horrific.
Yeah.
Did you see the,
the fights this past weekend?
The boxing match I did and I miss them.
I miss them.
It was a
name's Jay Dillon.
The WWE hall.
Yeah.
That's um,
that Canelo Alvarez fight was,
uh,
was uh,
was amazing.
Yeah.
They were talking to,
um,
uh,
Paul Williams,
who are the guy who crashed the motorcycle.
I was paralyzed from the waist down and he was one of my favorites.
Great.
Great fighter.
But he was struggling to talk.
I was listening to him talk.
I was like,
this guy sounds punch try.
I know.
You've seen cage matches.
You're going into that 15 foot steel.
Yeah.
She's going to do MMA.
Oh,
your opponent
really hurt is very great.
Well,
it is what it is.
You know,
the better man to come out.
Now.
Why do you believe you've been training and all this?
It's unfinished business with Andrew Gelada.
Uh,
can you give us any,
uh,
I don't know anything.
How are you going to beat him in a steel cage?
A terrible interview with this guy.
I'm going to beat
him.
Good.
Now you've been trained.
Yeah,
I mean,
again,
I tell
with this one,
but yeah,
he's,
he's where he needs,
he's pretty messed up.
If you look at the second one down,
it's an actual interview where he's talking,
he go no more.
Fuck.
It says so much to talk about.
Riddick Bowe
and this is in 2009.
Yeah.
The,
well,
the,
the point is these dudes,
they reached this point where it just,
uh,
it just all falls apart
and the,
and the crazy thing is it might not even be a parent during their career.
Lots of times you see it 15 years after they retire in lots of cases,
this is still a new sport.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean even boxing,
like combat in the way that it,
that it is now is,
is,
is very new.
Who did you tell her nation and I will help.
I think that was the difference.
And so I'll be able,
come on.
Oh,
not about that.
That was a,
that's the one.
And it's a shame because you know,
like,
I mean I struggle with the idea of that possibility myself as well.
And I think a lot of of,
uh,
the prevention of that can happen in the gym.
And I've spent years being the type of fighter that was like,
oh,
well I've got a spark because it's the only thing that would hold my attention
because I was so down on myself about the sport.
I was like,
you know,
not interested in drilling or learning technique.
I was like,
let's just get in and get out as fast as we can and,
and beat the crap out of each other and I'll be able to take,
to get,
oh,
I'll be able to wake up in the morning knowing that I have to do that.
And then I'll,
I'll,
I'll go on my timing,
we'll get better and everything,
but that is not the way to have longevity.
And so now I'm like loving myself again,
loving the sport again.
And um,
I'm realizing that,
you know,
the,
the less shots I taken in practice,
the less likely my,
my chin is gonna is gonna become glass as I get older in.
And the better I'll be able to have a functioning brain as I get older.
You know what I mean?
You gotta be smart.
Yeah.
The thing about taking punishment in the gym is a very real thing and it's,
people think that's the only way to do it.
I completely agree with your idea that you've had plenty of tough fights and you
know what a tough fight is like and what you need to do is just work on your
skill and working you conditioning and then execute come fight day that you
don't need.
The,
the battery that guys take inside of the gym is that it needs to be managed.
It really,
really needs to be managed and it's a real problem in this sport that um,
there's so many different ways to do it.
Nobody really knows the exact correct way to do it.
Yet this sports still in its infancy,
it really truly has us is by the way football,
when you,
when you talk about head injuries,
I've,
I the do the newest sports illustrated has Jim Mcmahon on from the,
the Chicago bears and I read it and I started about some friends about it and I
started watching some documentaries about it.
I've,
I've been paying attention to football only for this reason.
This,
this head injury thing.
Really?
Yeah.
It's fucking terrifying.
They did say it's only been around 50 plus years,
you know,
I mean all these guys are,
take some 20 years to,
you know,
and the career and then started having problems and then they're fucked
and we're,
we're slowly watching what's happening cause it,
cause like I said,
like some guys,
they don't even show symptoms until way later,
way after they retire.
You know,
once the,
once you get older in other organs,
stop being as efficient,
then all of that is brought out.
I mean,
you're scrambling your brain literally.
And the messed up thing about football is like what we were talking about
before.
Um,
they're using their heads.
I mean because the helmet protects your skin.
It protects your skull.
It,
your skull won't crack with the helmet.
That's what it's designed to do it in my opinion.
And if you look at it from like a physical standpoint,
it centralizes the percussion of the impact.
And so,
yeah,
sure,
you can ram your head into a steel post or someone else's helmet or someone's
body and you can rush at them with all the,
uh,
all the power that you've trained to do and use your head as a weapon.
And every time you do that,
you're,
you're creating a concussion.
You're creating,
you're,
you're causing your brain to bounce around in the skull,
literally.
And it's like,
they don't even feel that lots of times,
you know what I mean?
Like you can't,
like,
yeah,
you get,
you get a flash of unconsciousness or you feel like you get rocked and they've
got these big traps and everything and they work on their,
their neck strength to,
to,
uh,
help displace the impact for the rest of their body.
But it's like,
man,
you're,
you're screwing yourself up every single time.
And they,
and they don't even think about words with fighting.
It's like we've got these small gloves.
So when,
when you get hit,
you know it.
And then the,
there's like time when you got to stop and check yourself.
Like,
oh,
I got,
I got hurt.
You know,
and you,
and you know when you're taking punishment,
whereas with football it's just,
you can just go through the whole game and go through a whole career doing it.
Well.
And even in MMA,
um,
especially if,
you know you're not being managed by,
um,
someone or trained by someone who's like really paying attention to you and
monitoring you and looking out for you.
You know,
guys get tagged and then Jim and then they have to keep training.
Yeah.
Fight coming up,
man.
I'll tell you what,
they're there.
If there's great,
great trainers out there that,
that,
uh,
understand that and understand all the technical aspects of the mental and
emotional aspects and the health aspects.
I don't know of them and you know,
I'm not,
it's crazy.
You know,
like,
look,
I'm not like people are going to take offense because we've got all these
public,
highly publicized trainers,
especially in MMA right now.
But I've worked with a lot of people and I know a lot of the fires at work with
a lot of these other guys that I haven't worked directly with.
And I see anybody really being an amazing trainer as far as,
as far as monitoring the overall health.
I mean there can be,
I don't want to like say that there isn't for sure,
but if there is anyone there up and coming,
I can tell you that much.
And,
and we're still the sports still in its infancy to the point where I think it's
going to take my generation of fighters retiring and the few that are able to
understand fighting and understand the right smart ways to train.
I would love to.
I would,
I would love to be a trainer is just,
the only thing is I don't really know like how to segway into that.
Like as far as financially,
uh,
as far as the financial aspect goes.
Because I feel like if I just all of a sudden say,
Hey,
I'm training fighters now,
hey,
you know,
I need,
I will need at least one or two star people who are making decent money to,
you know what I mean?
To not only publicize the fact that I'm doing this,
but to,
you know,
to create,
uh,
an amount of revenue to make it worthwhile.
Because if,
if,
if I'm training a fighter and they're like,
at a high level,
I want to be there for them all the time.
I'm going to have to,
you know,
monitor every single thing they do throughout their entire training camp and be
a,
a monitor of them in the downtime as well and just,
you know,
be there for the fighter.
And um,
I just,
uh,
it's,
it's going to be an interesting thing to see if I can somehow segue into that.
I would love to,
but,
uh,
I don't know that it's necessarily readily available for me,
but a time will tell.
Well,
it seems like you could probably join up with someone who has good intentions
but isn't doing it,
you know,
what would you think would be correctly or you know,
or doesn't bring to the table what you think you would bring me?
You have more than 20 MMA fights.
How,
I mean,
I'm amazed.
I made a few count the fights on the sh on the show too.
I think I have like 35 or something like that.
But like I though some of them aren't on sure dog and stuff,
but I think,
I think I'm like,
like officially like 32 but then yeah,
I don't know.
Over 30 that's a wealth of experience.
Yeah.
And,
and a lot of,
and I've taken a lot,
especially in the latter years,
taking a lot of break,
like long break time in between fights just due to injuries and just taking time
off to reflect and things like that.
I,
I was able to work with gray a lot in me and gray have really good relationship.
Gray Maynard.
Uh,
we're actually really good friends.
So last fight when he was getting ready for Clegg Weda I went out of my way
because of the situation that he's in right now.
He kind of needs somebody to do that.
I went out of my way to try to,
to,
you know,
help him in a trainer type aspect.
But the same thing applies all,
like I live in la,
he lives in Santa Cruz and I just don't have the time or resources to be there
with him every day.
But I did watch tape of his opponent.
I fought as opponent,
so I knew it was opponent really well.
I,
I studied it,
you know,
a lot.
We took notes,
um,
you know,
and I help monitor his training in the,
and I cornered him and,
and I think that could be something that I want to do in the future.
It's just whether or not,
you know,
I have the facility or the,
the resources to,
to s
dark urine when you got to get along with,
I think that would be irrational person.
So I think it'd be a good,
uh,
it'd be a good fit for you.
And you obviously have a passion for the,
the development of a,
of other fighters as well as development of south.
Definitely.
And I'm,
I'm an analytical person,
so I,
you know,
I,
and I,
and I know the boundaries of over analysis,
so I feel like I could,
I could be a good person for,
for a lot of fighters.
I think you'd make a,
you can make an amazing trainer.
Yeah.
You're,
you're an open minded,
do two euros.
Always looking at different aspects.
Like can you tell me all the different shit that Ricoh was doing with you in
that?
By the way,
I'm also super happy to hear that Ricoh is working with somebody.
Again,
Rico was one of those guys.
It's like the lost talent,
you know,
Rico's a brilliant guy,
it all comes down.
There was a whole lot of things that I didn't understand that were going on at
the old rod.
Jim,
you know,
I was worried
there are folks who don't know.
Rico.
Ciavarella was one of the original trainers,
have a raw,
which was real American wrestling,
which was Henderson and couture,
but Vladimir Mighty Shanko,
all these like big named guys from back in the day and Rico chopper.
Ellie was always known as,
it's like really brilliant.
Super Analytical Guy who was wicked on the ground.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was one of those people who he understood body mechanics and,
and combat so well that it was so quick.
His transition from being a,
like a high level freestyle wrestler in,
in college and in on the world stage and then transitioning to being in
Brazilian Jujitsu,
someone,
someone who understood submissions and everything was just so quick and um,
he only had to be taught a few things too.
And like he figured out the rest of them self and I'm saying like,
you know,
maybe not in every aspect of life,
but in that particular aspect of,
of understanding,
grappling,
wrestling,
body mechanics and combat in general,
mentally,
emotionally and physically.
He's a genius.
And um,
yeah,
he was working with,
I was there with a couture and Henderson and Erickson.
Erickson had already left on good terms and couture and Henderson,
you know,
we're doing their own thing.
And when I got there,
it was me and vitamin Mattie Shanko and frank trig.
And then a few other guys like Fernando Vasconcellos who I'd talked about before
and some other fighters were always coming through while the dish mail was
there.
Oh yeah.
And I actually was his roommate.
Oh Man.
Yeah man.
You want to say she's who handshake,
man.
You ever see that?
It's a weird three finger thing.
Element.
Silly but awesome.
Yeah.
But uh,
Rico,
I mean I just had this quality and I don't even know,
I don't even think he purposely projects
it,
but people,
they want to be around him.
They want to hear what he has to say.
He's almost like a prophet,
like,
like brilliant in that situation,
the social situation of the gym.
Then it became too dramatic for him and he really doesn't like drama.
He doesn't like being surrounded by the scene of a gym.
You know,
like all these things,
they become scenes and then you know,
there's politics and you know,
people are talking about this and that and there's all this silly stuff going on
and it's no longer just about learning and training and competing.
It becomes this whole other thing.
And he got fed up with that.
Uh,
his way of coping with it may have not been the best way,
but like,
you know,
he had to distance himself from it and now I'm just like,
I couldn't be happier.
I'm just honored to be,
uh,
like a part of,
of what he's doing.
And he's,
that's what he told me.
He said,
you know,
like I would love to try to make one fighter great instead of just having some
big facility where they're a bunch of,
you know,
fairweather people come through when they want to and show up.
He's like,
I want to just focus everything.
I think as long as you guys have foiled on your tee shirts and like Japanese
lettering,
as long as you have that,
you know,
like you need a cool logo,
maybe something people can tattoo on their body.
I know,
I know.
Yeah,
that's it.
Well unfortunately the,
all the affliction stuff is,
is,
is going on a style so I can't like have patches across my back and safety pin
on to my other garments.
They fired my man,
Tom Atencio.
So I used to wear affliction stuff.
Yeah.
Tom's my friend and uh,
and also Tom,
I feel like a affliction MMA they tried to,
they tried to pay some fighters.
They tried to do a good thing.
They they,
yeah,
no,
no.
I just think the physical stuff they sponsor a lot.
Is that hardy?
No,
no,
no.
These sponsored a lot of fighters.
But I talk shit about them and I felt bad because I like when guys sponsor
fighters obviously for sure.
So I bought some of the dragon jeans and a warm to the weigh ins.
I made like a big deal out of it.
I still have a man,
my wife tried to set throw them away.
I'm like no,
no,
no.
You're not throwing out my dragon jeans.
I wore those things only for the Wayans.
I might've worn them for two.
Wayne's I announced it on the ut I will be wearing my dragon genes cause it's so
ridiculous.
Yeah it was.
It was so weird.
It was like all like all of the sudden
this subculture has these guys wearing these strange shirts where like things
are made to look like they're torn with little holes and little worn spots and
things stitched all oddly across.
Oh,
what's that about?
I don't know.
And then these strange like,
like we're bringing back like the heavy metal skull logo stuff.
It's like,
okay,
we'll do any of you guys listen to iron maiden and you remember like Eddie and
all that.
Do you remember Vic?
The,
the,
the Megadeath guy or anything?
And like they're just,
that's not even what it's about.
It's just this new retro thing that most of the people don't,
uh,
the nostalgia in it or that it is retro like Spray Tans Fo Hawks and then these
like flair boot cut bell bottom ish pants that are like have the same distressed
look about them.
And then those weird square toed shoes that are like patent leather or something
like that,
that come up really long.
And then all the sudden these guys are like,
I just,
it was the most absurd style I'd ever seen.
And I'm,
I'm so glad that that's kind of starting to fade away,
but I'm just leery of what is going to happen
place.
I'm cool.
I'm not sure what's more absurd.
The builtin holes or sagging,
I don't know which more ridiculous.
I think sagging is more ridiculous.
Even the guilt hotel
think sagging,
his particular ridiculous,
particularly ridiculous now because with,
with,
especially with the hipster type of culture and then hipster hip hop culture now
is tight jeans but sag them and it's,
that's the worst style ever.
Cause it's like if you got some big jeans,
you can sag them because they're big jeans and they're like,
I might not be into that.
But it's like,
you know,
you rock a little bit of a sag because you're wearing 38 size 38 genes are the
30 waist.
I get it.
But when you,
when you have these like these jeans that are made out of denim but they're made
to fit the way that spandex do and then you pull them down so that you can like
see your boxer shorts in the back.
It's like really hard to walk around.
They're wearing shoes like with no support these days and just like,
like the like glasses that aren't prescription that are just like,
you know,
like it's,
it's the,
it's the oddest thing in the world.
And uh,
I just,
yeah,
I don't understand style.
Like,
like I,
I don't,
I don't understand what,
what,
how these things get popular.
Why everybody,
you know,
sheep's together and,
and uh,
conforms to these absurd styles.
All it takes is one person who was like an icon or you know,
the,
the hero hero warship mentality that we have nowadays.
The cult of personality thing.
Is that what it is?
Cause it doesn't seem to be one person that created that.
It's been something that's sort of emerged.
It doesn't seem,
there's not like an example that I can look back and say,
well that guy was the first kind of that the awardee tattered jeans
thing.
It starts to happen and people are pushing for it.
And then what validates it is,
is some hero person and then the other hero person does it.
You know,
some,
some celebrity is a very strange society we live in with just the idea of
celebrities.
Yeah,
it is ridiculous.
I saw one,
a photograph of this guy who had others.
My fanny pack dragging chains.
That's them.
Those are real.
Look,
did Detroit dragon needs with builtin worn out spots?
I told you I wore them shits.
It's like,
wait,
do we have,
are we doing this with cars now?
Do we have cars that have Russell's and dense and the already you can't have
that.
People want shiny cars.
Cars are still shiny.
Cars represent your
uh,
you know,
like you made up go into a nightclub on the red carpet.
Cal was like wondering like,
wait,
what is that going to get popular?
Where,
where people are like kind of taking a hammer and bang a little holes.
There are car start being sold with,
with like rust spots already.
Where I'm from,
we have Russ,
I just got my shit.
Hail damaged.
You're uh,
you know,
like there's a lot of dudes who are like really into old cars though and they
don't even clean them up.
They just drive her around all fucked up.
They're like,
they don't like take a 65 Mustang and wax it and make it look nice and take it
out for it.
No,
they like to keep it dirty and fucked up.
I don't know people,
some people don't see it feel like they're,
they,
they're defined enough by who they are,
by their actions,
by their work,
by,
they don't feel like they're defined enough.
So they want to really put out this image and work really hard at it.
And they're always gross.
There's just something about people who try really,
really hard.
It's always there's something gross about it.
Yeah.
And then there's people that legitimately where something,
because that's who they are and need just,
you know,
that's what he like when Joey Diaz,
whereas like when he was wearing those sweat pants,
like it was in the Sopranos.
I remember he went through that phase.
If that's what that phase,
I don't give a fuck.
It's Joey Diaz.
I'm happy to see them no matter what he's wearing.
If that's,
I mean,
if that's what you feel comfortable with,
that's fine.
I mean,
I've always at some point like the slightly baggy jeans,
a cargo pants and a regular tee shirt,
just always like at some point I think I was skateboarding when that was kind of
in like,
do you know Mark Gonzalez is a skateboarder?
One of the most amazing people that in that subculture that,
that we've ever seen.
He's,
he's an amazing guy.
He's an artist and everything,
but he was wearing cargo pants.
I remember in this blind video,
is it blind skateboards?
Anyway,
um,
and,
and I just took to that and not because I wanted to be like him and I was like,
that,
that looks cool.
It looks comfortable.
I tried it.
It did.
And I've been on that same path for like,
like 17 years now or 18 years.
And before that it was just,
it was a very similar type of thing.
I've never,
I always thought the full hawk was ludicrous.
I mean,
I thought like the fohawk especially,
it was a,
and I,
and I was just talking to this,
this girl that I'm friends with the other day,
it's like,
okay,
when you're a little kid I,
and I think I was actually in the situation.
You're a little kid and you're like,
I want a Mohawk.
Like,
like they have like in,
you know,
like in the cartoons and stuff like that.
Punk Mohawk,
like a tough Guy Mohawk.
No,
you're night having that.
I'm not going to let you shave the sides of your head and have a Mohawk.
Well,
fine.
And then you know,
you take your mom's hairspray,
you lucky shelf in the bathroom and you try to smoosh up like your hair into
like,
like a Mohawk.
It's like,
I think I actually did that once.
And then I saw what,
what happened,
this was the fohawk circuit,
1987 or 86 and I smashed my hair up and I was like,
that's not good enough.
That's not going to cut it.
And then I put it back down and I gave up on it and I didn't think about it
until years later.
And all of a sudden I moved to La and there's people like smushing their hair up
into this little point.
And they came very different though.
It didn't become like pretending to be a Mohawk.
No,
it,
yeah,
it turned into its own thing.
But man,
what an absurd
that was,
show ideas,
talks about it.
He goes,
it's like you suck at some guy's Dick and he grabs you by the top of the head.
You're doing it wrong,
smacks you in the face and send you right back down.
I mean that's,
yeah.
And I knew a lot of people like,
like friends of mine,
like,
like good friends that were like cool people and I thought were with it.
And then one day I'd look and I'd be like,
dude,
you have a full hawk.
Like what?
What is that?
And they'd be like,
Oh,
what?
What?
What's the big deal?
And I'm just like,
wow.
Okay.
They are correct.
They are correct man.
Wasted
wonky ass hairstyle.
I know,
but it's just so ludicrous it,
it creates this itch and the only way to scratch it is by like telling people
that it's,
it's ridiculous.
Or by like actually going up to their head is put all haircuts are ridiculous.
You know,
your,
your decision to keep it short.
My decision has shaved my head.
Hair's crazy.
What did they grow it?
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous body part anyway.
Shit that you have to maintain and can cough on kind of what we're doing
lot.
I'd like to think it's a lot less pretentious than the full hog,
but yes.
Okay.
I guess I've,
I've,
I've dumbed down,
no,
it's just,
it is,
what you're doing is you're,
you're observing not just this weird phenomenon.
People like what you call style and it's a bunch of lost folks trying to
communicate like in,
in really boxy,
sort of confined terms who they are.
You know,
I have skinny jeans on,
but I'm sagging.
I'm like super cool.
I know a lot of black people just sagging makes me want to take your money and
I'm not even a thief,
but it makes me want to pants you and pull your fucking wallet away and run
because it's just,
you look like a goddamn victim.
I just,
I don't get it.
he fohawk and honor that.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Oh,
with just sweat and,
and lack of showering for hawk,
the shit juice Joe.
Whoa.
And again,
two heads before a show,
never three.
I was watching the,
did he do something awkward before they,
the can't do something awkward.
Yeah.
The Kat von d thing was one of my favorite ever because you can see Kat von d
look at him.
He told a story about a girl who had a tattoo of her dad as a baby on her.
Right,
right,
right.
He said,
well,
it's weird.
No guys come on it.
And Kevin,
he was like,
what the fuck?
You could see the look in her face right in the beginning of the podcast and
probably called,
no,
am I going to have to put up with two hours of this time?
Yes,
exactly.
That's what I was a little worried about it.
He went in deep early and she had never listened to the podcast.
Right,
right.
No idea what the fuck he was going to.
You know people who've listened to the podcasts like yesterday we had on your
buddy rich,
rich,
really,
really fascinating guy,
but he's listened to the podcast.
That's why when we were talking and he said,
what do you think of when you think of a Vegan?
We were like,
well two dudes blowing each other eating a salad.
He can,
he did.
He ended up,
of course not,
but you know,
if you were like some dude who was like,
like really on this podcast to express your,
and you didn't know that were retarded,
but you're,
you're comedians to the punch on.
It's like that.
Just knowing that about myself.
I mean if,
if,
if that's the joke,
look what is the funny thing about w two dudes upon each other eating this out.
That's what was funny in my head.
I would have had to say that about myself,
about it,
you know,
anything that I enjoy,
if that's what's funny.
But that's why I get crazy when like this Tracy Morgan type shit happens when
Tracy Morgan gets in trouble for saying that if his son was,
if someone's gay,
I stepped out of the right,
really sang and he's trying to say something totally outrageous.
That's just the funniest thing to stay in that moment,
playing on the,
uh,
on a sarcastic,
in a sarcastic way.
He's playing on the idea of,
of the stereotype that most people will think of.
Yeah.
Not even expressing your opinion.
So in order to get offended by that,
you know,
like it would,
it would have to,
it would have to be presented a bunch of different way.
Yeah.
That's really driving me nuts about this literal aspect of our culture lately
when it comes to,
when it comes to standup comedy,
it's because you're playing dumb.
You're playing dumb in order to call.
Gotcha.
On somebody.
You're pretending that co that comedy is in a really subtle and weird nuanced
part of human expression and you're just taking it literally.
You're choosing to listen to what he says and look what I have written down.
These are the words that came out of his mouth like that's ridiculous.
To take that out of context like that is it's a moron game and when you're
locked arguing with a moron about whether or not that should or shouldn't have
happened.
That's the choice thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just can't do,
it was a guy named Brian Holtzman.
It's one of my favorite comics in La that nobody knows about.
Some people starting to know about them.
We've got to get Brian Holtzman on the show.
I love the guy.
He's a great guy,
but his whole act was just saying the most preposterous mean shit.
He came on stage at the comedy store maybe a week after Susan Smith had drowned
her kids and it was like this crazy thing with his mother and drowned or
children and he goes,
I heard those were bad kids.
He goes,
ladies and gentlemen,
I heard they never put that blocks away.
They sat that close to the fucking TV.
He goes,
those kids will not be missed,
and it was just,
it was just ridiculous.
It was so ridiculous.
That was just this uncomfortable sustained laughter through the comedy store.
Like,
oh no,
but we were all scumbags.
I mean he was telling this to a bunch of dirt bags in the darkest most club
in Hollywood and he always went on.
Yeah.
And he always went on late.
They always put Holtzman on late.
So it was like,
you know,
probably like midnight or something on it.
So everybody had a lot of drinks that have,
yeah,
on midnight on a Tuesday when you're watching Brian Holtzman on stage at the
comedy store,
anything can happen.
But that,
that to me,
you're at a comedy club,
you know what I mean?
And,
and,
and
that's,
that's the art.
It's like how do you push the boundaries of,
of the art that you're doing.
It's like,
well,
my art is making,
if your art is making people laugh.
And there's all sorts of ways to go about doing that.
And we have a framework to work with.
You know,
we have it,
we're standing up,
we're doing a routine,
we're talking about things.
Why not go there?
You know,
like,
why,
why not do that?
Why does everything have to be so literal?
I mean,
yeah,
you don't have to like it.
Right.
And if you don't like it,
then that's fine,
but what did you come to a like a comedy place
or you know what I mean?
Some people are going to like some styles of Shawmanee and some people aren't.
You know,
it's,
but to pretend that it's literal is like pretending the x men are really
fighting aliens.
It's,
it really is.
It's like,
it's like pretending that that vampires can go outside and be sparkly.
They spark it on the side and they just want to romance you the fuck out of
here.
This is fiction.
Standup comedy is just,
it's just a form of expression and Brian's form of expression is derailing.
Conversations are really uncomfortable moments about coming on.
Tattoos of babies.
That was his move.
You know,
you got an understanding.
This is not what he really was onto about on a regular basis.
What are you sure?
I know the guy.
That's cool.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What's funny and what's not funny?
It's like who knows?
Until you try.
That's the other problem.
Sometimes the,
the,
the trigger between thinking something might be funny and pulling it,
you have a very short window where you were,
it's really gonna work and sometimes a bullet comes towards you and you're like,
do I let this go?
Am I letting this one got what we let in this book?
I'll let it go,
let it go.
And as you letting it go,
you go,
oh no,
this is poorly foe.
Do you know you're drunk and you're letting that one go and like you don't know
how to articulate it.
Correct?
Well,
yeah,
the,
there's the attention span of the audience to deal with,
you know,
like when to pull the trigger and when not,
and then there's just a difference in the demographic of the audience.
You know,
I don't know if you're going to do the same routine,
you know,
in North Carolina that you do in La or,
or whatever,
you know,
like it,
like how you're going to change that if you're even going to bother changing.
But I definitely,
I'm sure you'll notice a difference in the authenticy of,
of their reaction.
And you know that a lot of other different things.
I believe the word is authenticity.
Authenticity.
I do get punched in the head for list.
That's a,
every time I pull out like,
like,
like I exposed myself for being stupid,
especially with vocabulary or speech,
I can just always fall back on.
Then I get hit in the head
deuce.
But does seriously monitor that?
Do you say like,
okay the moment
I feel like a little weird.
I'm done.
Yeah.
Yeah I do.
I do it
cause you seem totally lucid.
I've known you for at least seven years now and you haven't changed at all.
I knew you before you ever got on the ultimate fighter training at legends.
Yeah.
You're always,
you're the same guy.
Yeah.
We were treated at the bomb squad.
The old old legend.
Yep.
But you know,
we both know guys from that era and before who are not the same guy now.
I know.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
my only,
my only fear is that,
um,
even though I'm monitoring it,
that it might come out long after I retire,
which is what happens to some people.
And if it,
if that happens,
I hope,
I sincerely hope that doesn't happen,
but if it does,
it's because the damage has already been done and there's nothing that I can do
about it from this point forward.
All I can do is train smart.
You know,
like,
like if you look at the way that I'm training now,
if you look at the way that like gray Maynard is training now,
like we are no longer like killing ourselves for this sport and hating every
moment of it just so that we can try to win and Baskin like the,
the wonderful glory of winning on that one night.
It's like you should enjoy every day and yeah,
it's like,
you know,
bad days are going to happen,
but you should enjoy every moment and have a,
and you shouldn't be physically hurting yourself.
Obviously you don't want to blow out your knee.
You don't want to hurt your back when you're training.
Why would you want to hurt your brain?
You know what I mean?
Like,
like this is something that we have to think about.
You have to train smart and you have to figure out ways to keep your speed and
your timing and your reactions on point and that at the same time not go in
there and hurt each other and you can't be hurting your partners either.
I used to beat the crap out of my training partners to the point where I had
like taken their,
their moral down to a peg to the point where they would never give me a good
spar because they were just worried about me beating the shit out of them all
the time.
And that's no way to train.
It didn't better me,
it was just me being like being so fed up with,
with my spot in the sport that sparring was the only thing that would hold my
attention.
And then I just became a bully.
Even these people were my friends and I'm not,
I don't have a bully personality,
but it'd just be like,
okay,
well we're sparring today and I'm gonna win the sparring session.
And then like that's what I'm trying to do and I'm trying to beat you up.
And like I would do it.
And these guys,
you know,
like they were afraid and like I would watch the anxiety just like bill off of
them,
like smoke before every fucking training session.
They'd be like,
Oh man,
like I got to go in there and spar with him.
Did you experience that a sparring with any people that same sort of anxiety so
he could see it and you're so sure.
Or
for sure.
Yeah,
like I experienced it that while I was at couture's,
even with the guys who I didn't feel we're at a higher level,
but like it was just every day was war,
everyday was war,
you know what I mean?
And like,
like I would go in there and,
and,
and it be,
it
would,
it would be daunting.
It would be like,
okay,
I'm exhausted.
I just did a ridiculous amount of cardio and weight training this morning and,
and it's 116,
17 degrees outside.
And,
um,
I've got to go back in and once I go in,
I'm going to warm up and everybody,
nobody's really going to talk to each other.
Nobody's going to discuss anything.
And we're all gonna try to like hit each other while not getting hit and like
day in and day out.
Then you start to,
I started the low,
the competition,
just the idea of competition bothered me.
I,
when I'd come home I would not want to play chess with somebody.
You know what I mean?
Like the idea of trying to beat somebody or best someone in a contest was just
overdone.
It would have made me feel sick and I was like,
I don't want to have any.
And that's why it was it.
It sucked so bad cause then I would fight and win or lose after the fight I'd be
like,
I don't want to have anything to do with fighting.
And then people would be like,
hey,
did you see the fights?
I don't want to think about fighting.
And I became like all disgruntled negative about it.
Like I don't know,
I don't watch that shit.
I don't want you to do like,
you know what I mean?
Like that's,
that's who I was.
And it was like,
well there's this ironic thing.
You've got this professional fighter and he doesn't even watch it and he doesn't
like it and everything.
And it was just me trying to deal with my personal life and like my career at
the same time.
And just,
it's like,
and it was w what are you glad I had the experience I think of when you see a
guy like Brock Lesnar jump in,
a guy who was clearly he's a freak athlete,
right.
But,
uh,
clearly also has had a very limited amount of striking.
Yeah.
And,
and Dawson doesn't feel comfortable on his feet and then all of a sudden these
fighting fucking Cain Velasquez and Shane car when he's in the big leagues right
away,
Randy coture and like,
what was that his third professional fight?
I try to look at things really objectively like,
like,
I mean,
there's one way to look at that,
which is what the fuck,
this guy doesn't belong here.
He didn't pay his dues.
Paul's though you got,
yeah,
yeah.
That's Matt Ball.
Right?
And that's one way to look at it,
but I really don't look at it that way.
Even the fighters that I don't like personally that our marquee fighters that do
like,
you know,
like make a lot of money in the sport.
I'm always happy to see anyone making money in the sport.
And it's like,
well this guy came from pro wrestling,
he was already making millions of dollars.
But you got to expect that,
especially with the heavyweights,
you got to expect guys like that to just come in every now and then.
And I think that we're going to see a lot less of it as a sport progresses.
And as it becomes this deal where new guys are coming up,
people are becoming amazing fighters at the age of 1617 now.
And by the time they're in their twenties they're ready to go.
We're seeing less and less of that sort of thing.
So it was like,
you know what?
Let them let them eat his cake and if it makes him sick then so be it.
And that's what it,
that's what happened.
It was funny.
Your cake and eat it too.
Metaphor there.
Let them eat cake
and if it makes him sick,
that's so be it.
And then it's,
you know,
seeing how you're so careful about your diet.
It's very funny.
Oh yeah,
man.
I feel like he's one of those guys that epitomizes that old joke about the young
bull seeing the cows saying,
hey,
let's,
let's run down there and fuck a cow.
And the bull says let's walk down there.
Fuck them all.
That's right.
What movies at from,
I don't think it's a movie.
Yeah,
it is an old,
old joke.
But then from a movie some there,
there was a movie.
Yeah,
I'm losing it.
I don't remember it,
but it's a,
it's a super old joke,
but the,
um,
the,
the idea that they would take him and throw him in there and the second pro
fight against a guy like near and they're like,
you're crazy.
Like you and me.
He might've won if Maza got,
he didn't stop.
Stop because it,
he was punching him in the back of the hand.
He might've won that fight on a Tko right there.
But it's still not worth it.
He doesn't understand the submission to know if you took such,
why do that?
When you got to freak,
you got a guy you know you use.
He needed someone who would listen to him say,
listen man,
we do this right and you're the greatest of all time.
You know,
if you,
if you really want to do this,
you really want to do this because if you don't really want to do this,
you just want to get paid.
You can just jump in there and see what you can do right now.
But you look at a guy like that,
you're like,
obviously that guy has some freak physical abilities.
You see them,
what ever see a video of him walking around in his hands,
no walks around us know can run a ridiculous fucking 40 yard sprint.
He can leap through the fucking air.
He's a,
he's a freak.
Yeah,
no,
I think like he was one of the few people who has the power to pull that card of
the fast track and he did.
And with a little bit of luck and a lot of ability,
he was actually able to win fights.
And,
and like,
as soon as you win a couple fights in a row,
especially against guys like Carwyn and,
and,
and um,
mirror and dog,
a couture,
it's like,
oh wow.
Well,
you know,
I see holes in his game,
but holy shit,
he's winning and he's beating great fighters.
He's the man,
you know?
And that's all it takes in this.
Yeah.
But when he fought ouster and he fought Alistair Overeem,
after having stomach surgery,
we had 12 inches removed from his colon and then he fought one of the scariest
fucking strikers to ever compete in MMA and got kicked repeatedly in the body.
Yeah.
I mean,
you got to go,
who is talking to you as someone talking to you is someone managing you because
what you guys got here is the craziest to him.
Yeah.
But that's the wrong way to look at it.
You got the craziest goose that laid the golden egg ever.
You know,
Brock Lesnar career could be an enormous,
enormous group.
The build up to him actually challenging for the heavyweight title could be him
fighting competitor after competitor.
I don't know.
You would have wanted to do it that way,
but he wasn't thing.
I think he just wanted a fast track to it and he's one of the few guys who had
the power to pull that probably thought he could beat all those guys.
Yeah.
And needed someone to look at him and say,
just listen man.
Yeah.
You just need,
you need a watch some Alster over in kickboxing bouts and understand what the
fuck is going on.
Right.
Because this isn't as simple as you throw a punch and then he throws upon like
every time you're punching he stepping,
he's measuring you.
He's going to step twice and then kick your fucking legs out.
And by the way,
if he hits you once your legs,
not the same ever again,
that Legg's done back guy.
You got to see the Brett Rogers fight.
Yes,
she is us.
He hit Brett Rogers with this fucking thigh kick.
He slams that shifted Brett Roger Stein and you see a look on Brett writers face
like a holy Shit.
What have I gotten myself into?
Because it was just steps up and it was like,
oh no,
more of these are common.
Like that was too quick.
There was too confident
ovary.
But it's like an experiment,
you know,
he's,
he's made,
he's turned himself into an equate a dangerous man.
Yeah.
He's a weird guy.
Right?
What a trippy career.
The God goes from being a skinny too.
Oh,
Fiverr who keeps das and how
do you think it's all horse?
Hey listen man.
I know when I take my Advil,
you know,
like lots of times there's just testosterone pills mixed in with it.
And I don't know,
I'm just like,
oops.
And then all of a sudden my testosterone levels are really high.
Just lucky for me.
They just haven't tested me yet.
But is it,
is it Tylenol?
They,
Julian Jackson,
that was what this doctor did.
And comparatively,
there's doctors fairly sketchy.
So,
uh,
you know,
look,
look how dumb you are as a fighter.
I'm tired of this bullshit naive act that these fighters pool.
Well,
I was taking the supplement and this doctor told me to tell this supplement or
it was an over the counter supplement.
It's like,
no,
shut up.
Just fucking admit that you're doing steroids.
But the,
but the track record is that a lot of these guys have learned to just deny,
deny,
deny it and then if they deny it,
I mean I've watched guys,
I'm not going to name any names,
but I mean there are guys that I trained with that would be like,
I've never done steroids before ever.
I would,
I don't know what they're talking about.
Like there was one guy in particular and everyone knows that he's on steroids.
He's a great guy,
but everyone knows he's on steroids.
And the the,
the mother of my child who was with at the time as a massage therapist for,
for athletes and she went over to his house and she came back and she's like,
how come he has in his house in the fridge,
all these vials and syringes and these,
these bottles that have like pictures of horses on it and stuff.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
why do you think?
And he's like,
yeah,
but he said that he never did that before.
It's like these guys would lie to their own mother about it.
They would,
they would like lie on their deathbed about it.
I don't know.
It's just like this shutting off the brain thing.
It's like just admit that you did it.
You know what I mean?
Like that goes back to what I was talking about before about this being an
honest authentic event.
Like this is why I do it.
Like you can't make anything up like it.
This is not a movie where you had 50 takes to get get the the the scene,
right.
This is a one time thing.
You're being honest with yourself.
All the training,
everything you do culminates into this.
Why do you want to like be a fake and a liar outside in in other ways and if you
do then that's your prerogative.
But it's like man,
like I could never live with myself.
Like going around telling people like that I that I didn't do something like
that.
It's like
no.
When doctors are giving you,
what percentage of guys do you think are using performance enhancing stuff
that's,
that's illegal for sure.
There have been a bunch.
I mean to just,
just to one thing to clarify,
there have been a bunch of companies who've been busted for putting stuff into
their supplements.
Just regular shit you buy at Gnc that contains illegal compounds and stuff that
we'll test you positive for steroids.
There's short and that's how they get results.
They're the,
what they're doing,
they're getting results by essentially selling you steroids,
just not telling you in the,
in the the the list of ingredients and it's a steroid.
People take it,
it works.
I mean there's been a series of different things that have been pulled from the
shelves and have proved that Victor contact guy has pretty,
it's talked pretty extensively about that and he's about as big of an expert on
the subject that you can get.
He's a former head of ball club,
which was a company that it created a designer steroid to mask a from the test.
So in his opinion there,
there's a lot of those false positives.
But outside of that,
what percentage of guys are using,
okay,
this is,
this may be a shot in the dark,
but I,
I have,
you know,
a,
a lot of acts.
I mean I know all these people and I know of them and I trained with him and I
deal with them.
I would say
at least 60% are on them all the time.
And I'd say up to 85 or 90% total,
have at least done them at some point or tried
now.
How did they,
how were they on them all the time?
And then they pass tests?
Well these guys cycle the stuff,
you know,
they take it and then they know how long it's gonna take for it to get out of,
out of their body.
And like,
and,
and when I,
in,
in when I said that 60 and 90% thing that I just thought of in my head that it
was my estimation,
I'm also talking about HGH,
human growth hormone,
which isn't something that is tested for right now just because it's hard to
test for it and it's very expensive to test for it and the commission is not
going to pay that kind of money and it's still very random.
You know what I mean?
Like I wish they would just test everybody.
Why?
Like instead of doing this random thing more,
hey,
you might get picked and you,
oh,
you may have to do the piss test.
It's like make us make it a requirement for,
we all have to all have to submit physicals and blood work before it,
before every fight,
before every fight.
We have to,
we have to do that.
And once a year we have to do,
um,
you know,
uh,
ophthalmological exams,
eye exams,
a dilated eye exams.
So,
um,
why don't we have instead of just HIV and hepatitis,
why don't we have anabolic steroids?
Uh,
you know,
one,
why don't we do tests
for the levels and all that stuff every time wise because it's,
it's too expensive and people are pinching pennies and that's,
and that's what the commission is doing.
That's the way I look at it.
And it's like test everybody and then we will have it.
You can either sink or swim,
you can keep taking the stuff and it can be a mental crutch for you and you can
feel like,
oh,
I can't,
I can't perform anymore because I don't have my steroids is what it's been
helping me win forever.
Or you know,
you can learn to live without it.
Like I do in like a few people doing.
It's just like train without it,
you don't need it.
I don't want to look back on my career and been and be like,
well,
I did some great stuff,
but I did that great stuff when I was taking all these steroids and you know,
while I was taking the steroids then that,
that's what helped me.
And it wasn't really all me.
I don't want anyone's help.
This is about the individual,
the martial artists.
This is about their journey,
trying to better themselves,
uh,
in the art with their technique and their training.
And it's just a,
it's a journey.
It's like,
why do you want to,
to,
you know,
screw that up
when you have a very noble point of view on this.
But how many people share it?
How many,
how many guys?
You know,
I knew,
I know there's guys like John Fitch.
I've had this conversation with John.
He shares a,
the exact same point of view.
And,
uh,
he very specifically said to me that he would never want to think that he
couldn't have made it without,
you know,
taking something,
even though he knows that it would make them a faster athlete,
it would make them better,
make them stronger.
He doesn't ever want to think that there's no way he could've made it without
this stuff.
How many other guys feel that way?
I don't,
I don't know that very many of them do at all.
That's an astounding number that you gave me.
The,
you know,
the on it all the time.
That's why no one's more,
uh,
no one is a more qualified to give that estimation then you are a guy like you.
The thing is like years and years of trading with different people at everything
and then like,
you know,
whispers,
start to come out all,
yeah,
he's on this,
you know,
you hear things never go public with it.
I don't know.
I usually don't talk to other people about it.
You certainly don't name names.
It's,
it's their prerogative.
They can play with it if they want.
But like the more and more I stayed in the sport,
the more and more I see.
Oh Wow.
I thought that guy was,
was clean.
I thought he wouldn't do that.
The thing with me was I had a certain amount of principles that I,
that I,
personal principles that I had when I came into this and it was just like,
I don't want to to,
to do that.
You know?
I just don't want that to be a part of my personal legacy.
Even if no one ever knew.
I believe you.
Um,
I know you,
I believe you what you're saying is absolutely true.
But do you know how few people are?
So,
especially p few people who aren't wealthy,
they're not,
you know,
they can't retire and live the rest of way.
You're so dedicated to those principles.
It's such a rigid and,
uh,
like,
a foundation of your character.
How did that,
how did that set in with your life?
when did that become,
I don't know,
martial arts attitude that you have?
It's not bravado.
I know you,
it's not like,
oh,
I'm not,
you know,
I don't need no bullshit.
And the kicker was US anyway.
It is more of a,
you know,
you are doing it all of the correct way in your eyes.
I,
yeah,
I just,
that's,
that's why I chose this.
That's why I'm not working for a corporation in a cubicle or something like
that.
That's why I'm not like,
you know,
I,
when I had those types of jobs,
I felt horrible about myself and about my life.
And when I finally decided to try to take MMA for,
for what it was and,
and dive myself into it,
100%,
dedicate myself to it,
I was like,
I had nothing to lose.
And I'm like,
this is a perfect path because I'm either gonna make it or I'm going to break
myself doing it.
And,
and um,
I mean,
I don't know what goes through these guys' minds.
They just,
it's just the idea of winning is too enticing in the idea of having an edge.
And I watch guys and I know people who became so addicted to that stuff that
when they don't have it,
then they have this insecurity in the back of their mind and their subconscious
and they don't think that they can actually pull off what they did when they
were on.
What did you think of when you saw like the pride era where you,
it was just super clear that no one was tested from nothing.
And in fact I have friends who,
uh,
fought in Japan,
we're told to take steroids or sure,
sure.
Uh,
almost all of those guys were,
and like [inaudible] and it's just while it was happening,
I was just in limbo because I was trying to work my way up in the lightweight
division and small shows where there's all these scumbag promoters that are just
trying to screw you over.
And I was like,
you know,
seeing the lightweight division be completely dissolved for a few years and,
and I was just like,
like,
wow,
like the closest guy to my weight that's fighting in any,
in any kind of show that's getting paid more than $10,000 ever is like,
you know,
it was like,
hi and gravy Gracie versus that each of the hour or whatever you like.
I'm like,
well,
looking at guys that would walk around at like 190 pounds and like,
that's,
you know,
so,
so it just,
it's,
I guess what I'm saying is,
it seems so other worldly to me that,
I mean,
I was MMA and I was interested in it,
but it was just like a,
it didn't apply to me.
I was just like,
well,
that will never be me.
Even if I did like throw my principles out the window and just decided to take a
bunch of steroids and still be a lightweight in frame,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and they like,
that would be silly.
Like I would,
I would look like that.
Is that,
remember that Guy Jimmy ambery?
Yes.
Yeah,
I've heard of him.
it looked like that.
You know what I mean?
Like that.
That's the only way I could get up to heavyweight.
That was 300 pounds and like five,
six I remember all the people do.
Yeah.
He was five six.
He's taller than me.
I'm sure.
I'm only five.
Eight.
How tall are you?
I
think he was like five.
Eight.
Yeah.
He's like 300 pounds of solid muscle and huge lats and it's just the,
he could never put his elbows in and learning a lot about technique.
And it's,
it's funny like a lot of people scoff at this cause they're like,
oh well you've been doing this for 10 years and you're learning now.
Like good for you.
It's,
it's kind of weird that you're learning.
Again,
it was like there's,
you can never master all of this,
but I'm really understanding that elbows in and bringing everything into the
core and almost like 99% of all the techniques you do is,
is very important.
And that guy literally could not do it because his,
he's in constant bench press mode.
He's ready to bench at anytime.
I'm like,
you know what I mean?
Just the way he walks.
But if that guy got on top of you,
Oh,
what a nightmare.
Yeah.
Strong dialect that gets on top.
Yeah,
sure.
And he was,
I think he's a black belt in Jujitsu.
He's a black belt under Carlson Gracie.
Oh Wow.
I don't know.
Yeah.
That's sad about the guy,
but yeah.
Yeah,
I guess I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
It,
I've gone off on a
long tangent,
but what I want to say is that watching that stuff with pride,
like my feelings were just like,
hopefully the spoiled change in the UFC did change it.
They brought in the lightweights and,
and you know,
I was able to,
to compete with,
with guys,
you know,
my size.
Yeah.
For folks who don't know,
Matt fought Mack fought and won 70 on the ultimate fighter.
And the dude that you fought in the finals,
Tommy was a big fucking here.
Yeah.
How many speakers?
A big fella.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was,
he was big.
Yeah.
And,
but,
but I knew like just from training with him,
he was very green.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and uh,
it,
I don't mean that in like the eco green census,
it's back the antithesis of that.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean,
he was a,
he's a dairy farmer,
you know what I mean?
That's like what he did.
He,
the guy had never,
ever eaten a pineapple in his life.
He had never eaten a mushroom and his life once,
he didn't know what a mango was.
Um,
and he didn't know what an avocado was.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And this guy was eating a bacon out of the package the way you'd eat lunch meat.
And he was,
and we were like,
Yo,
Tommy,
like,
die from that to die from that.
Yeah.
And he's just like,
Ooh.
I'm like,
no,
it's not pre cooked.
This isn't precooked.
And he's like,
Oh,
well,
I'm like,
he just,
that's just the way he,
who knows.
I mean,
this is a guy who was the only vegetable experiences,
like corn on a plate or maybe like,
like peas or something like that.
One once a year or something like that.
Yeah,
he was a,
he was a big,
big dude.
And um,
yeah,
I mean I just knew though that he was very young and his experience in his
understanding,
did they hook your diet?
You're a Vegan,
did they,
did they hook your diet up while you're in the home?
The one good thing,
even though with all of them,
the negatives
being there
in the no contact to or from the outside world,
no freedom.
The one good thing that they have is,
is you can food wise you can order pretty much whatever you want.
You tell him whatever you want it and he is,
as long as it's,
you know,
at whole foods or at the regular grocery store,
they'll go and get it for you as long as it's within reason.
So guides were even like ordering like,
like,
like the most expensive stuff they could,
they could get like they want like flounder from the Deli and like filet minion
and all this shit.
And like I yeah,
I was able to get it,
keep my diet like on point.
And,
and that was one of the things I established from the beginning.
Like I was worried about that kind of like the idea of guys being,
you know,
how be in jokesters and messing with somebody's food.
And like from the very beginning,
I just gave these guys that look like when I look at him,
like,
you're not going to fuck around with me.
I'm not going to be like,
like the butt of your jokes.
You aren't going to like,
you know what I mean?
P and mine,
this isn't my lettuce,
this.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's not happening.
You know what I mean?
And they never happened.
No one know someone's food.
So someone I think Rhonchi Yeah.
He's like,
I don't watch his show.
I've got better stuff to do.
No,
but,
uh,
the,
the um,
one of those,
uh,
seasons,
the season that Ryan Bader and um,
what's that kid?
Philippe Nover wa the season that they were on,
we had two different weight classes and someone peed and Ryan Bader and fully
know versus like,
like fruit or something like that.
And they peed all in it.
And those guys just ate it and they were cool with it and they didn't even think
anything of it.
And then like when they heard that it had had been peed all over it,
then they start feeling sick and we're like trying to force themselves to throw
up and stuff.
But yeah,
nobody messed with my stuff.
The only thing that happened was guys on my team,
like guys that I was supposed to be friends with were like eating my food.
And it was like,
look,
you guys can eat whatever you want.
You can order the same stuff that I order or you can eat your own food.
But my diet is,
is very specialized so don't take my stuff like it's public domain.
So I started like writing my name on it.
We even,
they didn't show it on the show,
but me and this other guy named Billy that was on my team grab this,
uh,
this like small refrigerator that was in the back,
um,
you know,
near,
near the grill,
outside on an outlet and like brought it into the room.
And it was like my personal like dorm refrigerator.
And I kept all my food in there and so yeah.
Nobody,
nobody messed with it or did anything with it.
It was just,
there was an issue.
I'd have to think about it though.
I know,
I know.
Yeah,
it was,
it was hard,
man.
It was hard.
I,
you know,
I don't know how I got through it,
but I did.
I would just kept on my eyes on the prize and I wasn't like,
when did you,
when did you switch your diet over to Vegan?
A 2004 yeah.
Yeah.
What did you,
what did you,
what was it like before then?
What was your time up until that point?
Okay.
Let's see.
When I was 16 or 17
I was kind of like,
I'm done with red meat and pork.
I just like for health reasons and just,
I don't know,
like my own halfassed moral for ethical reasons.
I was like,
I just don't want to mess with red meat and pork.
It's bad for you.
It's just,
I,
I don't,
I don't agree with it right now.
So I stopped that.
And then when I was about 19 or so,
I realized that all these ear infections and sinus infections that I had been
having for years and years,
like seriously bad ear infections,
like I would get them at least twice a year to the point where there would be so
much pressure that might,
your drum would inevitably a puncture.
And it was the worst pain,
the worst pain that you could think of.
I mean,
I've broken my femur before.
I've had all kinds of like bad physical pain.
Nothing is as bad as a few of those,
uh,
ear infections,
those ear infections.
Uh,
the pressure on the brain too,
you can almost feel too,
it's incredible and it's very sensitive in there.
And then I would get vertigo for like months afterwards and I don't know if you
know what vertigo is life like,
but it's absolutely miserable.
You can't,
you can't,
everything is spinning all the time.
And,
uh,
you,
you try to focus on different spots in the room,
like,
uh,
like the corner of a door or anything.
Just to force your brain to,
to remind your body that you're not actually spinning,
but you can't stop your eyes from doing that.
Like if I were to spin around and around in a circle,
you know how your eyes go like this and dart back and forth to try to catch up.
It's just like an involuntary reaction where your eyes are doing that.
But even close my eyes and try to like put my fingers on my eyes and they just
beat darting back and forth.
Kids your equilibrium so messed up and when it is okay you try to go walking
around,
you still feel like you're in an episode of cops.
Like everything's sort of bouncing around.
It's,
it's,
you completely feel detach.
It feels awful.
And so I dealt with all that and what I'm getting to with that is that um,
and this is a personal thing,
this is a personal allergy.
Not everybody has,
not everybody has to quit dairy because of this,
but dairy directly affects a lot of people within the sinuses,
the ear,
nose and throat.
That's why like if you drink like bought and milk feel like phlegm.
Yeah,
well I developed like a severe allergy to it and it was probably due to the fact
that I was drinking milk constantly growing up.
Like my mom thought that,
that,
you know,
she believed the,
the bullshit,
like,
you know,
grow big with milk,
like osteoporosis,
strong bones and all this crap.
And I was drinking a ton of milk growing up and um,
I think that contributed to my allergy possibly.
But,
um,
anyway,
I,
I tried all sorts of stuff and I finally came to the realization after reading
some stuck stuff from,
uh,
Andrew Weil who's the dude with the beard,
the,
the home,
or not homeopathic necessarily,
but like holistic medicine guy.
And he was like,
if you have problems with your sinuses or ear infections,
eliminate milk and all dairy products.
I did and I haven't had a single problem with your infection since then.
So that was when I was about 19.
So I bike spent 10 minutes off on a tangent.
You asked me what,
um,
what my diet was like before 2004 when I went vegan.
The only thing that separated me from having a Vegan Diet,
uh,
was chicken and fish and the reason why I was eating and maybe Turkey,
you know,
like poultry and fish.
And the reason why I was eating that stuff is because I believe what everybody
had said beforehand,
that you need,
uh,
some s some type of animal protein in your diet.
And also like out.
I like chicken,
you know what I mean?
I like the salty,
greasy stuff.
I like the flavor,
you know what I mean?
It was,
it was cool.
Even like regular grilled chicken breast or whatever you put seasoning on it.
I was like,
well,
this is what I'm supposed to eat.
And so I would eat that stuff.
And um,
I was,
you know,
the thought to myself,
okay,
one day when I'm done trying to be an athlete and when I don't need this animal
protein that everybody says I need,
I will stop eating that and I'll have a vegan diet.
And what I told myself was I will not call it Vegan.
I will just live like that.
I will not wear it on my sleeve.
I won't become part of some calls.
I will just do it because I feel that it's the right thing to do as a consumer
in this day and age.
And I want to,
I want to address that too.
It's,
I don't think,
I think we're made,
we're on divorce were made to be able to either eat meat or vegetables,
uh,
you know,
and plants and nuts and everything or a combination of both.
And,
you know,
depending on where people lived in and like what part of the world they lived
and what they had access to and what they could hunt or not be able to hunt for,
they would eat a combination of both or just one or the other.
And this is the,
and,
and we have the ability to do either,
we live in a day and age now though,
where,
uh,
it is not,
we're not the hunter gatherer anymore.
Um,
it,
you know,
if I live back in the day,
or whatever,
some hypothetical situation,
hundreds and hundreds or thousands of years ago,
I would,
if,
if that's what I had to eat,
that's what I would eat.
I have compassion for animals and all living things.
So I would,
I would feel bad about it,
but I would respect what I killed the much,
like I feel my soul tells me that much like the way that a lot of native
American tribes did.
They like revered the animal.
They killed it.
They ate it,
they used everything.
They didn't waste it and they respected what they did.
And it wasn't like,
yes,
like I want to hurt this thing.
It was like,
this is our food.
We have to kill it for food that's different than this day and age where you
have a uh,
mass amounts of suffering.
Even in like a lots of people that are vegetarians at eat milk and eggs and
things like that.
It's like the,
the,
if you care about the animals at all of the moral issue is still the same.
These animals are living in horrible situations and they're suffering like
whether or not you like animals or think that they have like the same,
you know,
a bill,
uh,
abilities to,
to reason or you know,
have any emotions or anything like that.
The one thing is,
is true.
They feel pain and they can feel pain and they live in the worst,
most fucked up situation.
So I was just like,
look,
I'm a consumer.
I don't want to be,
if I,
if I could live exactly how I'd be,
I'd be like living off the land somewhere.
But that's just like,
like a pipe dream.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a consumer.
I buy stuff if I'm going to buy stuff and I'm gonna like,
like contribute directly to things that I buy.
I don't want to contribute to this industry.
It's just,
it's just wrong for me and I don't want to tell their people what to do or force
it down their throats.
And that becomes a religion.
Yeah.
You'd never approached it that way,
which is why I respect that.
I've had many conversations with vegans that were enlightening and equally as
money that are annoying.
Sure.
I think we all have.
And it becomes one of those things where they're excited to let you know that
they're Vegan and they're just a,
it's,
it's like a thing that they push.
It's all over their stupid Twitter.
It's just,
it's a,
it's a constant.
I battle with that a lot because a lot of the people who follow me,
like through social media,
I'm not on Facebook by the way,
but I'm on Twitter.
But like,
like a lot of people that follow me and,
and that and that are fans of mine and like hold me in high regard,
they're part of that scene and I don't dismiss that scene,
but like any scene,
it tends to push people away.
And like a lot of these people are really passionate about what they believe and
they believe in animal rights,
which I believe is a,
is a,
is a noble cause and it's something that should be treated seriously,
but they get so frustrated and then they turn it into a them against us type of
attitude.
And they want to force it down people's throats and they want to,
they want to like,
you know,
it turns into like a religious type of thing and,
and this type of thing where you're either with us or you're not,
and we're going to criticize people that don't,
it's like a lot of people aren't vegans because they just,
they,
they just aren't educated.
They don't understand what's going on.
You end up pushing,
you end up putting more people under the defensive in pushing them away from the
cause.
Then then you do educating people when you're like,
oh,
I'm part of some exclusive club and like,
you know,
like we're all,
we've all got a name for it and you have to follow these exact rules and if you
deviate from that,
then you're discussing and oh my God,
meet is disgusting and everything.
It's like that,
that whole,
that whole thing.
It's like I don't,
almost all of my friends eat meat,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like I'm watching more and more people not,
but like I never ever want to make somebody feel defensive about what they do.
If they have questions,
I answer them.
You know what I mean?
And,
and I tell him why I'm doing it and I'll,
a few of my close friends after years and years have just recently
done the Vegan thing and they're like,
dude,
how come you didn't like,
like,
like kind of tell me about this more earlier.
And I'm like,
because like you're either going to do it or you're not.
I don't want to like be the guy that forces people to do things or tries to like
tell him,
oh,
you're wrong because you're doing that.
Most people are just victims of consumerism and they're victims of,
of misinformation.
Like we all are in so many ways.
And the nutrition thing and like what's going on in the world with diet is,
is no different.
And so it's like,
why,
you know,
don't force people away with your cultish ways,
educate people.
And if they don't come around and they don't come around,
that's fine.
We're not trying to like change the world and create an,
you're not trying to,
yeah,
some people are,
some people,
that's what I'm saying.
Vegan becomes just like being a Mac user and they just,
are you using windows still?
It's the team.
It's a team mentality,
you know what I mean?
And it's like,
like they've picked a side and it's like I f I f I feel bad about criticizing it
because a lot of these people that are involved with this are really good people
and they're,
they're noble people that have taken that choice because they feel it's the
right thing to do.
And,
and I'm with them on that 100% but what's,
what's hurting it more than helping it is the attitude of it being like the,
like it turns into this scene.
It's a moral high ground thing as well.
And so it's a chance for someone to say that they're better than you.
It gets real weird,
you know,
lead by.
So what happens?
Yeah,
yeah.
People get defensive.
Lead by example.
If you,
if be enjoy your life now because of it,
people will be gravitating towards that idea.
They see success,
they want to imitate it.
That's,
that's the best way to get someone to change their diet.
That's the best way to get someone to change their life lead by example,
but when you start being a sanctimonious Douche bag and we're talking about let
us,
you can go fuck yourself.
Right,
right.
It gave puts,
it puts people on the defensive already knowing it's like anything else.
Yeah,
so so then they've created a divide and when you create that divide there's the
line becomes very hard to cross again because people are like,
if people are ready,
stereotype me.
They're like,
oh,
like as soon as they hear the word Vegan attached to my name,
they're like,
oh great,
like here's this Douche bag and he's just going to be talking about his diet all
the time and telling me that I need to repent for my sins and everything I is
hipster jeans,
people that people don't understand like I chicken and fish and in like meat
products all through growing up and everything.
Like I like,
I'm just like everyone else.
I just said to myself,
I feel that this is wrong.
I don't want to contribute directly to this anymore.
And like,
people love to argue about stuff,
they want to pull up hypocrisy that you know,
like,
well,
you know,
I guess I probably like hit some bugs on the way here and my,
my petroleum powered car and like,
you know,
like I've got like a,
like,
like whatever I'm,
I've bought that were again
Anik from,
from Chili the other day.
And like,
like all the,
you know,
like the economic issues that they are not economic,
sorry,
environmental issues that come up.
And it's like,
yes,
you can,
you can point out.
Hypocrisy is,
but I don't,
I live by the set of rules that I've picked because I feel that,
that it's right.
I don't,
I don't feel that I should be contributing as a consumer directly to these,
these industries that caused nothing but suffering.
And that's my thing.
And like,
if somebody doesn't want to do it,
they don't have to,
and we're still on the same ground and I'm never going to shove it down.
Anyone's.
No,
you're not.
And that's a,
it's one of those things where,
you know,
which,
what you're showing is what,
what I said earlier about you,
about your unwillingness to take performance enhancing drugs or to be a part of
the year.
You're doing it because of your principles,
right?
Look,
would be a way better world if we all live by a real set of principles.
And that I think is one of the underlooked things that martial arts,
true martial arts provide.
And I think that,
um,
we should empathize but emphasize that as much as we emphasize competition
success,
we should emphasize the ability to enhance your development as a human being.
Because that's really what martial arts are spectacular for.
If you've never get into a fight in your whole life,
you,
you develop skills through difficult work and through,
you know,
building your character and responding to pressure and stress and,
and it makes you better at everything.
They do evolve,
whatever that means to you.
But,
but,
but try to evolve,
move forward,
you know,
like,
like build,
build off what you're doing.
And I we won't,
they'll need to get on the steroid thing and give.
But I just want to say like,
like this is one thing that I wanted to touch on is I've never done them.
But the one time that I actually considered it,
there was a point in my life that I actually was like,
well I just didn't know anyone.
I was like well at the time I was like I,
if I had access to it I might,
I might go ahead and do something like that just cause I just need to like make
money.
And that was me responding to the lowest point of my life.
That was the lowest point of my life.
Like it like as far as depression goes in the sport and everything.
And I was almost willing to like go ahead and entertain the idea and I came to
that through weakness.
And so all I'm saying is maybe you know,
if,
if people are as great as they say they are,
you don't need it.
And I don't really don't care if the other guys are doing,
I don't care if the guy that I'm fighting is doing it and he thinks it gives him
an edge and maybe give him an a given him an edge.
I just,
I'm doing this for me,
I'm not doing it for my opponent,
I'm not doing it for the sport.
What
do you think about the future performance enhancing trucks is the real issue to
me is not things that you introduce to your body but rather what you do to
change the way your,
your,
your body behaves and reacts.
When you talk about like gene therapy and when you talk about the improvements
in our understanding of genetics and certain switches and different mechanisms
inside the body that trigger muscular development,
recuperation and all that stuff is going to eventually be manipulated.
Well what happens to mixed martial arts when that happens?
People,
people are sheep and they know that.
They know for the most part they really are.
And so whatever is is considered,
um,
whatever is established as the moral norm will be.
Okay.
Like right now,
like we're in a situation where everybody's like mad,
like all mark McGwire and mad at Barry bonds and mad at these players for doing
all this stuff.
But if somehow they're able to legitimize a different type of,
of a,
of performance enhancing,
uh,
you know,
scenario like,
like what you're talking about like gene therapy or,
or whatever.
Like if the,
if they're able to legitimize that socially,
like,
like an an uh,
an an ethical way,
then as long as the public thinks it's okay,
then everybody else started doing it.
I think,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it all depends on,
in bright.
Now the public for the most part seems like they feel like it's wrong to go
ahead and agree to not take steroids and then like a lie about it and then,
and then go in and do it.
And,
and I think that's,
you know,
that's,
that's a good way of,
of thinking about,
by the time we also realized in some sports,
there's no matter what you're getting at the footballs,
one of them,
when you look at the size of those guys,
you go,
what is going on?
What has changed so radically that people are that enormous?
You know,
what's going on there?
Well,
who knows?
Is it pro hormones in the meat?
You know,
what is it?
It seems like there's certain heights of size and strength that you can't reach
without supplements.
Yeah,
it's,
to me,
it's a weird thing because this is a mere blip and human development.
I mean,
if you go back just a hundred years ago,
there was nothing,
there was nothing you could do you,
you ate good food.
And that's it.
When 100 years is the tiniest amount of time,
you can even measure when you start talking about the universe.
100 years is a joke,
you know?
I mean as far as like change and that the radical change in what we've been able
to do and manipulate the human body.
When you watch like Rickerts well,
um,
the singular you do,
you know,
his,
uh,
his movie about the singularity,
what is it?
What is Ray Reiki?
A transcendent man.
And it's all about the technological singularity that like avoid it whether or
not you want to avoid it.
Like there's people that like,
you know what,
I just read books.
I don't go on the Internet.
I don't even have an email.
That's all good,
but you're,
you're not going to stop it.
It's swarming around you whether you're accepted or not.
And I kind of have the feeling that that applies to all aspects of technology
improvement and innovation,
including the manipulation of the human body.
And it's going to be really strange when they start figuring out a way to turn
virtually every person you see into of Vitaly Klitschko into a giant super
athlete.
I mean,
we're going to be able to do very strange things and manipulate the body in very
weird ways in the future.
Yeah.
If it's,
if it's,
you know what I mean?
Like that.
That's,
that's all it comes down to.
If,
if it can create entertainment for the people paying for it.
And it also will change life as we know it.
If the organic body ceases,
did peak come finite,
if the organic body is a renewable thing that you can constantly replace limbs
on Ann's to constantly fix Oregon's and,
and literally we changed the whole idea about having a lifespan.
Yeah.
I mean it's not as simple as cheating in MMA.
It's as simple as like we're going to transcend the boundaries of our biological
nature and that that's something where MMA has sort of caught up in the
periphery of that.
Like the,
the improvements that we've been able to do to sport science and you know,
I love that word,
that term sports science and it's basically just the body,
right?
How it was about it's science,
biological science,
the improvements that we've made just in understanding diet,
nutrition,
supplementation and training.
All of that is pretty substantial,
but it's nothing compared to what they're going to do once they introduced
genetics and all of sudden you're Elian,
you know,
I mean,
we're going to have a weird world.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
you know,
and that's interesting too because,
um,
like,
like evolution has happened a lot.
I think if I'm correct,
uh,
through like mutations that happen,
you know,
like on a,
like on a hormone level or a cellular level,
uh,
within,
within people.
And if,
if that mutation happens to be advantageous to have in the current environment,
then that moves on,
you know,
rather than like,
like the person adapting to the environment.
It's like,
it's like,
here's a chance,
you know,
here's a mutation.
She says a little bit different,
you know?
And so we're able to actually,
we're at the point where we're actually able to manipulate that manually or
we're going to,
and that's just a fascinating,
yeah,
it's fascinating.
And I th and as strange as it is,
I don't feel like it's completely unnatural.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like ideas unnatural,
like,
like in a primal way.
But,
but like,
I feel like that's just what we're kind of rolling into,
you know,
as a species.
I completely agree.
Yeah.
Everything's natural.
Even pollution.
Sure,
sure.
A natural aspect.
We've pulled ability to control their environment stuff and it's also the lack
of discipline,
the ability to have,
uh,
the ability to say,
let's move this over there without you ever having to figure out how to move
this over there.
You're just a guy with a crane,
right?
Let's dig a hole and throw it in there.
How can you dig that hole show efficiently with some brilliant person figured
out how to make this monstrous machine that moves ground very easily and you
come along with very little responsibility for that.
And very little.
It's like winning the lottery.
Like all of a sudden you have this money and the money goes away.
You have power,
you have an earned you,
you,
you haven't developed the character control that it's a strange city situation
that we're in now with all this technology.
It's like,
like how many people actually know how to engineer the iPhone?
You know,
really like,
I like all these things that we're using,
like,
like the,
the,
the uh,
the knowledge of it is so specific that we don't know.
And that's why like the software guy knows nothing about what the hardware guy
knows and vice versa.
And lots of times,
neither one of those guys can change a tire and they sure as hell can't identify
what plants are poisonous and what plants are edible in the,
in the wild.
So it's like we're just,
we're,
we're on a a very strange path and I don't want to like necessarily judge it or
criticize it as being like completely negative and evil or,
or wonderful and beautiful.
It's like,
it just is what it is and we're,
we're,
people are doing what they're doing.
Um,
I personally feel like more people should,
should get in touch with the actual earth,
which is,
you know,
we are products of the earth where this is our,
this is our cradle,
you know what I mean?
And this is like where we we're born into and I feel like people should get in
touch with the essence of the earth more and just be like understand the earth,
but don't go close to bears and take pictures of me and motherfuckers.
There is a reason why they have a 50 yard rule when you go to Yellowstone.
Some asshole got eaten recently and Oh really?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure he's not an asshole.
You fucked up.
I shouldn't call him an asshole.
He probably has a lot of friends at miss him.
I apologize for that.
But yeah,
homeboy of took pictures of a bear for eight minutes for an atum oh eight
minutes of photos.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
he fucked up.
Wow.
Yeah.
We camp you got to take,
you've got to be really respectful of nature.
We've got to really understand that there's a food chain going on.
You,
you,
you just,
you're lucky you don't have a real place in it.
A natural place where they consistently hunty you sure.
But you go out there,
that's your,
your well
what I been by like being in touch with the earth isn't necessarily like going
out and trying to,
you know,
live with the actual animals.
I mean this guy wasn't living with him.
It was just taking pills or like,
like expose yourself to,
I mean like we understand that.
Yeah.
I understand it and just understand how it works and,
and,
and it would be great if people understood,
I mean,
look at,
look at it this way.
Like we're supposed to be these amazingly evolve people and we're like superior
than everything else on the earth.
Okay.
Well why is it that every single other species living on the planet,
you can,
you know,
unless it's in a completely alien environment,
like a penguin and the desert,
most of the time you set it out in the wild,
you take a deer and you,
you set it out in the wild,
it's going to be all right and lets it gets hit by a car killed by a person in
knows what plants to eat,
what plants not to eat.
It knows where to go to get water,
knows how to go after are we don't know anything you didn't,
you know,
he'd take it like a person,
even though that is like an outdoorsman and,
and,
and put them in the wild and there's,
there's a chance that they,
they're not going to survive
the thing I watched survivor man,
you know,
it's fucking hard just to be outside of course,
just to be outside for a few days.
It's hard to think about the hypothetical scenario.
I'm not trying to get all like paranoid doomsday like that.
I'm just saying it,
you know how many people it obviously,
right.
We're going to be deal if that happened,
we're going to be dealing with the urban environment and what's left of it in,
in in many ways field.
But yeah,
it's like if you are in the wilderness,
like how,
how are you going to survive?
Are you going to be able to make a run for the wilderness?
I think most people would just end up staying in an urban environment,
even if it's all rubble and just trying to get together and,
and,
and gross fake.
Something happened in that,
in that way.
Because I don't think that people are going to be able to live in the wild.
I want to live off the land.
I think that'd be the most romantic thing ever.
Have a house by lake,
eat fish,
grow your own vegetables,
go hunting.
Stetting it's the way to go.
It just takes too much goddamn time.
I want to write comedy and go to class.
You've got to hunt.
Yeah.
You can't combine that with,
with the format of the way of life.
Yeah.
That we're living in now.
You'd have to take a step away from that.
And that seems,
maybe it's just a,
like a romantic idea to me.
Maybe it's like naive to think this way,
but I would,
I would like to step off of the grid at some point in my life and live my life
that way,
you know,
for,
for the remainder of my years,
you know,
I don't know if it'll ever happen.
Um,
it might be just,
you know,
a pure fantasy.
Um,
but if I'm able to,
I think that that would,
I think I would learn a whole lot more about myself and about the earth than,
than I would in any other way.
And I would learn about a lot more about the essence of,
of,
of being a human being rather than just,
you know,
waking up and doing the same thing every day.
You know,
the,
that we do in society nowadays.
Have you ever thought about doing your own podcast?
Did I have,
yeah,
I actually do that.
Yeah.
I want to,
I just don't have,
I don't know,
like
I'm not good with,
uh,
like I dunno,
like I,
I'd have to set the whole thing up like where to host it and like a,
you know,
like I like all the technological things I have to learn about all of them.
And I got em,
I take the technology pretty well,
but I have to research it and I,
you just don't trust all my retired friends do it.
You could do it.
Yeah.
Everyone I know has a bar.
Ari had the little,
um,
the,
the what?
The quarter's zoos.
Yeah.
So I actually got one of those.
And Mike's,
I just don't,
I,
you know,
I had just had to start organizing it and then figured out where to host it and
how to put it on iTunes and all that stuff around what to do.
You could do it and you've got a lot of shit to say about things.
I think a,
there's,
uh,
there's only so much you can express yourself when you're on the ultimate
fighter,
right?
Or when you're,
you know,
in post fight interviews,
I mean,
it's like there's not that much time where people get a chance to sit down and
get to know you.
But I think you're a,
you're in an admiral.
You're an admirable example for young men as far as like to your principles as
far as having a code that you live your life by,
which I think is something that's really absent in a lot of people in this life.
You know,
you are another example of a guy who's gone through a lot of adverse situations
and developed a great character and resolve because of that man.
So,
uh,
this is a great podcast.
I really enjoyed it and I think people are going to enjoy this too.
They're going to get a different sense of who you are and you know,
we all need to hear these kinds of stories about,
um,
about turning your life around,
about developing,
you know,
your character.
I mean these are all like really important stories for people to hear it.
They're empowering and I think they allow us to learn things without having to
go through your experience.
We can learn from your interpretations of your experience and if we're presented
with similar problems or similar scenarios in our life,
we can learn,
we can learn from what you learned and what the people before you who express
themselves that you learned from,
from their experiences as well.
It's very important,
man.
And so,
uh,
thanks a lot for doing this.
Thanks to do this again and I'm so sorry I fucked up before.
But according to Twitter,
everybody's enjoying the shit out of this.
So cool.
It's all legit now.
Yeah,
it will be saved on Twitter.
And if people want to get in touch with Mac,
you can get him on Twitter.
It's Mac Danzig,
MMA,
whoever you are,
you dirty bitch that has the Mac Dansik give it up to the man.
You know,
that's his name.
Why you playing games,
man?
What are you doing?
Your name ain't Mac dancing side.
There's a few real live Joe Rogan's out there.
It's not that unusual.
And I'm sorry if you have to take a lot of shit because of me.
It's not my fault,
but a Mac Danzig,
MMA on Twitter,
uh,
tonight,
at the Ice House comedy club.
Again,
it is a cro Raisie fucking stupid pack show with Joey Diaz.
Greg Fitz Simmons,
Duncan Trussell,
Ari Shaffir,
Brian Red,
Doug Benson did.
I mentioned anybody not.
Did I say Joey did Mary and me,
you Fox.
It's going to be incredible.
Um,
and uh,
we're going to take a little break and then we're going to be back with Billy
Corbin.
Billy Corbin is the director of cocaine cowboys and he will be joined by Matt
Flavor Cock Sucker,
who's gonna lay it down and let you know what the fuck was really going on in
Miami in the 70s.
Joe Rogan,
the 70s.
Very intense conversation I had with him about this yesterday.
Thanks to will on it.com go to o n n I t.com and get yourself some Alpha brain.
You dirty bitch improved the way your brain functions.
Son,
don't snore it off your keyboard though.
I don't think that Shit's recommended.
Really fucked me up.
Like I almost had to leave because that like it started really felt like it was
fucking,
you really did snort it.
No,
I inhaled it through that big straw like so it's all this powder in my mouth and
whatever's in that like really made me feel fucked up.
Like I was really fucked up.
Oh,
you're such a unique person.
Go to [inaudible] dot com using code named Brogue and save yourself 10% off any
supplements and go to desk squat.
Get yourself some delicious desk squat stickers,
some yummy squad tee shirts.
And,
uh,
and then,
by the way,
it supports the desk squad podcast network,
which,
uh,
is a,
the only place to hear the icehouse chronicles,
which is the one that we do from the Ice House with all these bad ass comedians.
All right.
You freaks.
We'll see in a little bit.
Thank you very much.
And we'll be back.